Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Cap a fog jam, keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes.
I remember typing Dan's game, forehead swift rage, PJ salt and fail fish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Cap a fog jam, keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes.
Still hear his bark in the morning hour, he calls me, his doggy emotes reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat I get a feeling that I missed emotes from yesterday, yesterday.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Cap a fog jam, keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes.
So, ja, auf geht's.
Was ist das denn?
Pipiga please.
Ich ahne Schlimmes, wenn das Video mit einem XQC Abode anfängt.
Ah.
Es ist...
Ich dachte er singt jetzt Pipiga please oder so.
Aber es ist erstaunlich, wie viele Twitch Songs es mittlerweile gibt.
Scheiße.
Döner Kebab ohne Drehspieß.
Also überhaupt noch Döner ohne Drehspieß.
Max was hältst du von den Ryzen 4000 Mobile Prozessoren?
Ich hab ganz wenig zu gesehen.
Das was ich gesehen hab war nicht schlecht.
Kann ich aber nix wirklich Gutes jetzt zu sagen.
So was schlägt uns? Was schlägt uns denn?
Moment.
Es wird zu nem Emote reacted jetzt schon.
Meine Güte ey, wer kann auch echt zu allem reacten?
Müsste mir nur noch reacten zum Reaction Video zu Kekwe.
Stimmt es war noch die Zeit, wo manche Autohersteller Notebooks gemacht haben.
Ich glaub da war Ferrari nicht der einzige.
Also hat das Notebook nicht besser gemacht.
Alles war gut.
Android Hacking.
Also Hacker Mans wieder am Start hier.
Bleibst du jetzt bei Vodafone oder wechselst du?
Ich bleib bei Vodafone.
Das beste ist ja, dass es halt preisleistungsmäßig und auch vor allem von dem was es an Bandbreite gibt.
Das beste ist was es bei mir gibt.
So die alternative Telekom ist bei mir jetzt nicht so geil.
Hätten die mal die letzten Jahre bisschen mehr Zeug ausgebaut anstatt weiter auf ihrer Kupferleitung um zu reiten.
Dann würde das wahrscheinlich anders aussehen aber ist halt nicht so.
Also irgendwie sind die YouTube Empfehlungen heute nicht so spannend.
Ebi ist nicht so viel Spannendes dabei.
Wir kriegen halt der 4 Games Video von vor 7 Jahren empfohlen.
Excellent.
SimCity 5 war das nicht wo Kronk das Let's Play Rage quittet hat?
Ich erinnere mich da, da war dunkel was.
Das war so eines der ersten Games wo sich die breite Öffentlichkeit über verbackte Spiele aufgeregt hat.
Das wäre ein nettes Video. CPU Battle History.
Oh meine Video Vorschau ist mal wieder kaputt.
Meine Video Vorschau hat sich schon wieder verabschiedet auf dem zweiten Rechner.
Mein Audio Interface, das habe ich ja bei USB am zweiten Rechner angeschlossen.
Das spackt in letzter Zeit rum, da geht manchmal das Sound nicht und dann hängen auch alle Videos.
Wobei das wahrscheinlich an Chrome liegt.
Minecraft Speedruns, so interessant das klingt, war eines der langweiligsten Dinger die ich bisher gesehen habe.
Hast du das Simplicissimus Video zu Starlink gesehen?
Ist Starlink nicht die Tesla Satellitengeschichte?
Starlink
Simpl
Wie schreibt man den? So?
Ne fast. Schick mal einen Link kurz zu. Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Aber die Videos gehen meistens.
Starlink, ach das da.
Da bin ich bei, ja das können wir uns angucken.
Der Sebaro ist da. Sebaro hast du schon gesehen, ich habe ein extra Emote für dich noch hinzugefügt. Ich weiß nicht ob du es findest.
Hör mal gespannt, oder Chat entdeckt das neue FFZ Emote oder Better Twitch TV Emote was ich hinzugefügt habe.
Kein, kein richtiges YouTube Emote, das geht auf, äh, kein richtiges Twitch Emote.
Der Chat hat schon entdeckt.
Der Chat hat schon entdeckt, ja klar.
Der Grill ist schon lange dabei.
Ich weiß nicht ob es dem Chat gefällt.
Irgendwie sind die Video Empfehlungen heute nicht so spannend muss ich sagen.
Wir fangen mal wie immer an mit einem, wir gucken uns als erstes das Battlefield Top Play Video an.
Der darf natürlich nicht fehlen.
Der darf nicht fehlen.
Ich kann mich immer wieder wegpissen wenn ich den Scheiß sehe.
Ich werde nie verstehen wie die Mainstream Leute im Gehirn ticken.
Diese ganze Bitconnect Veranstaltung, die hat so groß Scammed drüber stehen gehabt.
Vom Ankündigungsvideo bis zu dem Modell was sie sich ausgedacht haben, da stand riesengroß Scammed drüber.
Größer könnte da nicht Scammed drüber stehen.
Und die Leute haben ihr Geld reingesteckt.
No, no, no.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ich werde es nie verstehen, ich kann manche Sache absolut nicht nachvollziehen.
Guck mal wir kriegen Nat erklärt, oh das ist Big Brain.
Das ist jetzt aber zu spät, weil die Abschlussprüfung für die Leute die Fachinformatiker machen ist schon vorbei.
Übrigens da habe ich ein schönes Video auf YouTube empfohlen bekommen.
Ich glaube das ist aber eher Cringe und zwar, wartet mal, hier.
Azubi für einen Tag, Fachinformatiker.
Es ist schon mal ein gutes Zeichen, dass das Ding 309 Dislikes hat und die Kommentare deaktiviert hat.
Also wir wissen ja, dass deaktivierte Kommentare schon mal in der Regel für absolut high quality Content sprechen.
Das ist bestimmt zum Fremdschämen das Video.
Wahrscheinlich ist das einfach nur eine Firma, die sich als besonders geil darstellen will und es geht überhaupt nicht über die Ausbildung.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Den Vortrag haben wir glaube ich noch nie zusammen geguckt.
Das ist einer der besten Vorträge, den sie je gehalten haben dort auf CCC.
Ich weiß nicht auf welchem Kongress das war, 2017 oder 15, 16, keine Ahnung.
Der hat drei gute Vorträge gemacht.
Auf der hat bestimmt noch mehr, aber drei die ich kenne.
Der hat die Spiegelmining Geschichte gemacht.
Dann die Bahnmining Geschichte, und den Xerox-Scan.
Das ist ein schwieriges Wort Leute, sprecht mal schnell hintereinander aus.
Ach du Scheiß das ist ja ein mega Zungenbrecher.
Probiert das mal.
Xerox-Scan, Xerox-Scan, Xerox-Scan, Xerox-Scan, Xerox-Scan, Xerox-Scan...
Ey.
Da bin ich, da bin ich zu, zu schlecht für.
Das ist wirklich schwierig auszusprechen.
Xerox scan.
Alter.
Zehn Mythen über das Darknet.
Okay, das kann man sagen.
Das Darknet.
Das sind nur Hackermans.
Das wissen wir doch alle.
220 Leute.
Redet jetzt Xerox scan.
Ich sag nicht Xerox scam.
Ich sag Xerox scan.
Scan, einscannen.
Nicht, nicht scammen.
Most popular streamers on twitter.
Oh, das kann man uns auch noch angucken.
Ist Pokeman mittler?
Oh, Virgin Shack.
Pokeway.
Gucken da wirklich so viele?
Also ich würde sagen, einer der beliebtesten,
der most popular Twitch-Streamer ist tatsächlich
MontanaBlack.
Der so ziemlich alles im deutschsprachigen Raum
und wahrscheinlich gibt's da bei irgendwie 40k
oder so auch internationale Zuschauer.
Ich mein, der größte wird's nicht sein.
Aber ganz vorne mit dabei auf jeden Fall.
So, Ninja ist weg.
Ninja hat mittlerweile glaub ich auch noch 6k Zuschauer
zwischendurch.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, wer der größte
Twitch-Streamer zurzeit ist.
Shroud ist auch weg.
Shroud gibt's nicht mehr, der Akte.
Ja, Ninja ist definitiv rich as fuck.
Da hast du recht.
TimTheTatman ist groß.
XQC ist zwar groß, aber nicht so groß.
Das gucken wir uns gleich mal an.
Moment, das haben wir doch schon offen.
Letztens gab's ne Umfrage auf Twitter.
Mal keine dämliche Umfrage.
Hat er letztens seine Umfrage rumgeschickt,
um zu wissen, welche Todesfälle von berühmten Leuten
in letzter Zeit einer Meisten mitgenommen haben.
Und ich kenn ja kaum Celebrity.
Ich kenn mich weder bei Schauspielern aus,
noch bei irgendwie Sängern, Bands, sonst was Großartiges.
Also ich hab da überhaupt keinen Plan.
Und da ist mir wieder eingefallen, wie viele Leute,
die jünger waren oder in ähnlichem Alter waren wie ich
immer zumindest im Internet kamen,
die die letzten paar Jahre in den Löffel abgegeben haben.
Also am meisten geschockt hat mich,
weil ich noch viel Overwatch gespielt hab,
war die Geschichte mit Internet Hulk,
falls ich noch jemand erinnern kann.
Sein letzter Post auf Twitter war,
er kriegt eine Spritze gegen Mandelentzündung oder sowas
und zack, zwei Tage später tot.
Dann kam TotalBiscuit, der ungefähr in meinem Alter war.
Dann kam letztens noch InControl, der StarCraft-Caster,
der war sogar noch jünger als ich.
Internet Hulk war auch eine Ecke jünger als ich.
Alter, was ist hier los?
Muss ich jetzt Angst haben, dass ich demnächst auch...
Das sind alles Sachen, die haben mich schon mehr mitgenommen
als irgendwelche Celebrities oder sowas.
Natürlich sind es letztendlich in dem Alter nach wie vor
Einzelfälle, aber man sieht, es kann ein echt jederzeit
überall treffen.
Also die drei Sachen haben mich schon mitgenommen.
Am meisten muss ich sagen, war die Sache mit Internet Hulk,
wo ich nie im Leben dran gedacht hab,
weil ich hab ja relativ viel Overwatch gespielt in der Zeit
und das war einer der bekanntesten, wenn nicht der bekannteste,
eigentlich der bekannteste deutsche Spieler,
auch international einer der besten,
hat gerade eigentlich aufgehört mit Overwatch
und wollte zu League of Legends als Coach wechseln.
Das war Quack-Quack.
Nachher hat ich glaube ich rausgestellt,
der hatte irgendwelche Herzprobleme oder so,
aber das hat man absolut nicht kommen sehen.
Dann gab es ja noch TotalBiscuit,
der hatte ja eine Krebserkrankung,
eine total seltene Krebserkrankung in dem Alter.
Normalerweise kriegen das 80 plus Leute,
der hat es glaube ich mit 30 oder so gekriegt.
Und als letztes gab es auch InControl,
der StarCraft Caster,
das war ein Blutsgerinnsel in der Lunge oder so.
Alles Sachen, die dir auch passieren könnten.
Das stimmt Renax, wie die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass den Löffel abzugeben wird, umso älter du wirst immer höher.
Jedes Jahr, jedes Jahr hab ich die Chance,
dass die Löffel abgeben.
So ist es.
Die Nintendo-Radio-Geschichte kann sich nicht entscheiden,
welche Lautstärke sie macht.
Weil das ist jetzt wieder lauter.
Wir fangen mal an.
Mich interessiert die Maus-Poppela Twitch-Streamer.
Interessiert mich echt.
Was haben wir da?
Riot Games, okay, die bleiben,
wenn diese Channels mitzählen,
dann bleibt Riot Games ganz weit oben.
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen,
dass Riot Games nach wie vor auf dem ersten Platz sind.
Ja, Arztbesuchen macht dich auch nicht unbedingt gesünder.
Das Einzige, was es bringt,
ist wenn du manche Vorsorgeuntersuchungen machst,
dass du halt Sachen früher merkst.
Und die meisten Sachen sind ja relativ gut zu überstehen,
je früher man sie merkt.
Wird nach Follower gemessen?
Ich denke mal, ja,
ich denke mal schon.
Aber jetzt nach Follower nachgucken
ist ja unfair, ja.
Also Syndicate kennen wir vielleicht noch teilweise.
Das ist der, der so Zombie-Videos von
Call of Duty Black Ops da gemacht hat.
Nadeshot,
ehemalige Optik-Pro, glaube.
Da hat er jetzt nicht seine
eigene Orga gegründet,
letztens erst. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich verfolge das nicht mehr,
so restlichen Kram kenne ich jetzt nicht.
So, schauen wir mal, wie sich das Ganze entwickelt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Syndicate
so ein riesen Ding war.
Äh,
warum bewegen die sich nicht?
Die müssen sich doch in der gleichen,
in dem gleichen Zeitraum müssen die doch zwangsläufig
bewegen. Kann doch überhaupt nicht sein, dass die
absolut keine Veränderung haben.
Ja, das sind Channel 2015.
Aber Riot Games holt wieder auf.
Keine Chance, dass Riot Games
irgendwie da, Riot Games ist bestimmt
immer noch ziemlich weit vorne.
Lyric, ja, das war also 2015.
Einer der wenigen ohne Webcam,
der richtig gut abgeht, also,
aber das ist auch noch eine andere Zeit.
DSL, okay.
Summit, klar, der ist auch am Start.
Soda Poppin,
der war damals auch voll am Start, ja.
Weiß, die sind dort alle noch am Start, aber ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie beliebt die noch sind.
Ja,
ich glaube,
das ist das erste Mal,
dass ich das seit awareness
talking durch next 입
jetztOkay,
coming, coming, coming, coming, coming.
puterige
بتüte
wird
sie, die
Jetzt dürfte sich da ein bisschen was ändern. So ab jetzt ist Twitch langsam richtig Mainstream geworden.
Trout, ja, der geht ab.
Ninja.
Und danach ist er auch gleich wieder weg.
Ja, später oder so, eineinhalb Jahre später ist er dann wieder weg.
Doktor Dysphos beachte, da hab ich ja gar nicht dran gedacht. Klar, den gibt's ja auch noch.
Hab ich schon nie geguckt. Trout hab ich ab und zu mal geguckt, aber bei den Channels ist nichts dabei, was ich regelmäßig gucke.
Ja, aber Ninja ist gleich wieder weg, weil Ninja gleich auf Mixer wechselt.
Und Trout auch, aber Trout ein bisschen später.
Warum ändert sich eigentlich bei Doktor Disrespect nichts? Da muss ich doch was an den Zahlen geändert haben.
Pokimane, Virgin Shack, Poki W. So sieht's also aus. Ja, okay, aber Ninja ist ja gar nicht mehr hier.
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, Leute, ich gucke davon nichts.
Ich gucke davon nichts.
Also insofern, Trout ist auch nicht mehr da.
Guck da gar nichts von.
Most popular MMOs, das hatten wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Ranking App, was haben die denn sonst noch so für Stats?
Top Selling Manga, oh nee, das ist hier für unsere Reap-Fans.
Most popular Websites, ich glaube, das haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt. Nee, können wir uns nicht angucken, wenn das vor einer Woche ist.
14 Views, Moment, der Cloud, der Cloud einfach nur, der Cloud die, die Sachen.
Der Cloud, die Videos.
Oder? Das haben wir uns doch schon mal angeguckt. Ja, die klauen, die, die klauen die Stats.
Das ist alles von Reddit. Das ist alles von Reddit geklaut.
Es gibt, es gibt, wie heißt denn das, dieses eine Subreddit, das ist alles von Reddit geklaut.
Das ist alles von Reddit geklaut. Es gibt, es gibt, wie heißt denn das, dieses eine Subreddit dafür.
Data, irgendwas, da gibt es.
Data ist beautiful, genau.
Das ist alles hier von geklaut.
Das kommt alles aus diesem Reddit hier.
Wenn ihr da durchscrollt, werdet ihr die ganzen Sachen finden, die ihr in diesen Videos seht.
Alles, alles, alles geklaut.
Alles gut. So, mit was fangen wir an? Was hätten wir zu bieten? 10 Mythen über das Darknet.
Wie Elon Musk das Internet revolutioniert, da fangen wir jetzt mal mit an mit.
Illuminati, Alter, Tribulon.
Aja ja, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es für Gaming taugt.
Weil, weil, ich meine, du musst erstmal ins Weltall und zurück. Das ist Latency-mäßig nicht so gut.
Ist das Video zu laut oder passt das so?
Der Antrag für 30.000 weitere Satelliten wurde bereits gestellt.
Moment, ich hab mal ne Frage.
Wo stellt man einen Antrag, dass man Sachen in ein Gebiet schicken darf, das niemand gehört?
Natürlich in den USA, wahrscheinlich.
Natürlich. Fragt man sich halt, warum kann die USA da drüber entscheiden?
Oder warum kann die ESA oder wer auch immer, oder die Inder oder die Chinesen oder wer auch immer, das entscheiden?
Das müsste ja was Internationales sein.
Ja, das wäre das Logischste. Das müsste irgendwas international quasi, wo man sich drauf verständigt hat sein.
Weil, ansonsten kannst du ja wohl schlecht ein Land entscheiden, so nach dem Motto, ja, wir gehen nehmen 30.000 Satelliten, die überall um die Welt kreisen.
Die Geschwindigkeit könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das funktioniert. Latency-mäßig, ich weiß nicht.
Naja, also, also, also. Sagen wir mal so, 1150 Kilometer, das ist ein bisschen näher als nach China. Wie viel ist denn das?
Luftlinie, Deutschland, keine Ahnung, Hongkong.
Luftlinie-Org, das alles gibt alles.
Okay, also, das ist, Luftlinie? Luftlinie. Also, von hier nach Hongkong sind es 9000 Kilometer.
Das heißt, die Entfernung ist nur ungefähr von hier nach Ungarn oder so, Ungarn-Rumänien-Grenze.
Das geht tatsächlich, das ist gar nicht so weit weg. Das ist gar nicht so weit weg. Das ist Latency-mäßig nicht so das Problem.
Es ist, es ist immer noch kacke im Endeffekt für, wobei, so schlecht. Also, 340 Kilometer ist jetzt nicht das Ding.
Das ist wirklich nicht das Ding. Man muss natürlich sagen, hin und zurück logischerweise.
Also, man muss immer, das muss immer, das Ganze doppelt nehmen.
Aber wenn die, wenn man, sag mal so, nenne mal die Mitte, 500 Kilometer, das geht halbwegs.
Das geht, also, Latency-mäßig.
Latency-mäßig.
Excellent.
Genau, die sogenannte Latenz soll bei Starlink um einiges...
Wer ist das? Kenne ich nicht.
Big Brain.
Kommt hin. 20 Millisekunden, wenn das wirklich noch, das kommt hin.
Ich mein, die reine Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist es ja nicht.
Das Ding muss ja wahrscheinlich auch, irgendwas wird ja da mit drin gemacht und sei es nur Relate.
Das wird wahrscheinlich länger dauern als die reine Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Aber 20 Millisekunden klingt doch nach, nach einer realistischen Geschichte.
Äh, was macht da oben eigentlich das Fenster?
Okay.
Okay. Warum, warum erhöht, warum erhöht Elon Musk nicht einfach die Lichtgeschwindigkeit?
Ja, klingt auch sinnvoll, klingt sinnvoll, ja.
Ja.
Übrigens, by the way, 80 Milliarden.
Man muss sich jetzt mal die Summen der Corona-Hilfspakete oder sonstige Sachen angucken.
Also hätte man über die letzten Jahre verteilt mal da ordentlich Geld ausgegeben und auch ein bisschen Druck gemacht, dass das passiert, hätten wir das durchaus schon haben können.
Man muss das nur wollen.
Ja, also, was, was für mich da ein Risiko ist, dass man komplett, also mal angenommen, man würde sagen, okay, wir bauen selbst kein Internet aus, sondern benutzen nur noch Starlink.
Das Problem ist, was ich sehe, dass man komplett seine Infrastruktur abhängig macht von X, ja, von irgendjemand.
Das heißt von den USA, von Starlink, von Elon Musk, von sonst was.
seine Infrastruktur abhängig macht, von X, von irgendjemand, das heißt von den USA,
von Starlink, von Elon Musk, von sonst was, also man macht die Versorgung der Bevölkerung
bzw. eine der wichtigsten Infrastrukturen, die es zurzeit gibt, abhängig von paar einzelnen
Faktoren, auf die man wenig Einfluss hat. Das ist ein Nachteil. Ja und natürlich, was
passiert, wenn die Dinger kaputt gehen, zerbrechen, sonst was, und es sind ja auch viele, da ist
halt sehr viel Müll dann auch am Start. Aber mal schauen.
Reflektieren das Sonnenlicht und können dabei so hell leuchten wie der Polarstern. Das kann
ein großes Problem für die Astronomie werden. Satelliten können nämlich helle Spuren auf
astronomischen Aufnahmen hinterlassen. Man hat schon immer Satellitenbahnen gesehen in
astronomischen Aufnahmen, wenn es einer der Tore ist, kann man die noch mit Bildverarbeitung
heraus korrigieren. Das ist Professor Steinmetz. Aber wenn es ein ganzes Gitter ist, was von
solchen Satellitenketten erzeugt wird, dann ist letztendlich ein Teil der astronomischen
Forschung nicht mehr möglich. Als Reaktion hat SpaceX nun auch einen dunklen
Satelliten namens Darkset in den Weltraum geschossen. Ob der wirklich deutlich weniger
reflektiert, weiß man noch nicht. Aktuell befinden sich insgesamt 2.218 Satelliten im
Weltraum. Ich glaube, es liegt wirklich daran, dass man nur an dem Licht, oder auch weil
die einfach davor sind. Wobei, wenn die davor sind, sollte eigentlich egal sein. Ich meine,
wenn man sich anguckt, was Aufnahmen aus den Wäldern, was die für Belichtungszeiten haben,
dann macht es eigentlich keinen Unterschied, ob da mal ein dunkler Satellit durchfliegt
oder nicht. Wenn der jetzt natürlich Lichter hat, ist doof.
Objekte, die dann ebenfalls in rasender Geschwindigkeit die Erde umkreisen. Ja, mal davon abgesehen,
den Büll ist halt noch da. Die Musik im Hintergrund hier, was soll ich das machen? Naja, das ist
Blödsinn. Also, das mag sein, dass das funktioniert, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das
funktioniert nicht hundertprozentig. Früher oder später wird es mal knallen. Und wenn
es knallt, dann hast du Teile, die auf andere Teile knallen, die wiederum knallen. Also,
ich glaube nicht, dass man da irgendwie so ein Ausweichsystem auf Dauer was bringt.
Damit können Objekte im Weltraum aufs Genauste lokalisiert und verfolgt werden. Starlink-Satelliten
sollen nach ihrer Lebensdauer von 5 Jahren außerdem wieder Richtung Erde fliegen oder
in der Erdatmosphäre verglühen. So soll der Orbit nicht zugemüllt werden. Trotz all
dieser Maßnahmen wäre es letztes Jahr fast zu einer Kollision mit einem Erdbeobachtungssatelliten
der European Space Agency gekommen. Die ESA hat aber zum Glück rechtzeitig ein Ausweichmanöver
durchgeführt. Wenn am Ende etwas so richtig schief gehen sollte, würde nicht nur SpaceX
darunter leiden, sondern die gesamte Welt. Professor Burkhardt befürchtet, dass Elon
Musk mit seinem Projekt trotz der zahlreichen Risiken viel zu schnell agiert. Wenn man die
Welt verändert und andere darunter leiden oder beeinflusst werden, dann sollte man doch
bitte zuerst einmal mit ihnen sprechen, bevor man es dann auch so macht. Außerdem sei der
Weltraumvertrag ver... Ich hab gelesen, die versuchen jetzt mit irgendwelchen Lasern Weltraumschrott
wieder runter zu lasern. Weil wir schon so viel haben. Also, immer mehr Unternehmen und
Länder wollen den Weltraum zwar nutzen, es gibt aber keine zentrale Behörde, die wirklich
die Kontrolle darüber hat. Noch dieses Jahr wird SpaceX vermutlich mehr Sateliten im Weltraum
haben als alle anderen Staaten und Unternehmen der Welt zusammen. In wenigen Jahren könnten
es über 95 Prozent sein. Damit würde ein einzelnes privates Unternehmen auf einen Schlag
fast die gesamte Verantwortung für unseren Orbit tragen. Ja, da hab ich auch so meine
Bedenken.... könnte unseren Blick auf den Nachthimmel für immer verändern. Da hat der
Mensch seinen eigenen Himmel kreiert, dann ist es nicht mehr dieses Gefühl, hinauszuschauen
in eine unberührte Welt. Das wär mir wurscht. Aufgrund der geringen Bandbreite pro Satellit
sollen erst mal nur abgelegene Orte mit Internet versorgt werden. Alleine diese Märkte sollen
SpaceX bereits zwischen 30 und 50 Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr einbringen. Mit mehr Satelliten
könnte Starlink dann auch dicht besiedelte Großstädte erobern. Der Markt, der Starlink
vermutlich bald offen steht, ist grenzenlos. Gleichzeitig wird die Instandhaltung mit
besseren Raketen und leichteren Satelliten immer günstiger. SpaceX könnte einer der
dominantesten und profitabelsten Internetanbieter der Welt werden. Ein schneller Internetzugang
geht mit Bildung, Wohlstand und Fortschritt einher. Ein großer Teil der Menschheit hat
bis heute gar kein Internet. Vor allem in Entwicklungsländern könnte Starlink diese
Lücke schließen. Auch im Internetentwicklungsland. Ich wollt grad sagen, da gehören wir doch
zu. Deutschland könnte Starlink dabei helfen, die Unterschiede zwischen Stadt und Land auszugleichen.
Dabei weiß bis jetzt niemand so genau, wieviel das Starlink-Internet überhaupt kosten
wird. Die Zahl, die im Internet kursiert, stammt aus einer Rede von Musk aus dem Jahr
2015. Gehen wir also mal von 200 Dollar aus. Das wären dann allerdings nur die Anstrengungen
der Verkaufskosten. Die andere Zahl, die man online findet, sind 80 Dollar pro Monat.
Sie stammt aus einem Interview mit SpaceX-Präsidentin Gwynne Shotwell. Um die 200 Dollar für das
Terminal und knapp 80 Dollar pro Monat für den Vertrag. Das ist okay, das wird wahrscheinlich
mit der Zeit noch ein bisschen billiger. Aber wenn es die einzige Alternative ist, die man
hat, warum nicht? Das ist doch okay. Wie könnte sich eine amerikanische Familie vielleicht
leisten? Eine äthiopische, aber niemand. Ja, das stimmt. Bis jetzt gibt es Aussagen.
Moment, Moment. Da heißt ja auch nicht unbedingt, dass in Äthiopien jede Familie sowas dann
bräuchte. Vielleicht stellt man dann dort einen Router hin und macht, was auch immer.
Da gibt es ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Aber die Möglichkeit, dass man erstmal an
abgelegene Orte am Arsch der Welt die Chance hat, schnelles Internet zu bringen, ist ja
schon mal was.
... von Elon Musk, keinen Grund anzunehmen, dass die Technologie für die Ärmsten bezahlbar
sein wird. So besteht die Gefahr, dass Starlink die westliche Welt in ein neues Internet-Zeitalter
katapultiert und Menschen in Entwicklungsländern sich diese Technologie einfach nicht leisten
können. Starlink hat wahnsinnig viel Potenzial. Die Vorstellung, dass jeder Mensch Zugang
zum Internet kriegen könnte, ist großartig. Doch das Projekt hat auch viele Fragen.
Ich finde ich persönlich viel eher schlimm, dass es 2020 noch nicht der Fall ist.
... die geklärt werden müssen. Wie macht man die Technologie bezahlbar für alle und
nicht nur für die, die eh schon recht schnelles Internet haben? Wie verhindert man, dass uns
ein gewaltiger Trümmerhaufen auf unserem Planeten einschließt? Was bedeutet es, wenn
der Orbit... Einfach die Erde ein bisschen verschieben.
... theoretisch immer noch uns allen gehört, aber dann doch irgendwie nur einer Person.
Da sehe ich auch das Problem drin.
... und viele offene Fragen und SpaceX und Elon Musk Schuldenantworten. Wir sind gespannt,
wie sich Starlink entwickeln wird. Cheers.
Exzellent.
In Dr.Watson's Video erfahrt...
So, was haben wir sonst noch hier zu bieten? Mythen über Darknet, der Auer, der wieder
Sachen wasserkühlt, irgendwelche Lego-Konstruktionen, Battlefield-Top-Plays, Azubi für einen Tag,
doch Lego-Konstruktionen. So viele Lego-Konstruktionen. Irgendwas von Linus Tech Tips, Battlefield,
Battlefield-Top-Plays. Das ist ein cooles Video, das habe ich schon geguckt. Zumindest
... Ausschnitt zwei... Azubi, okay, okay. Alle. Früher oder später gucken wir auch
alle. Azubi. Ich habe... Dieses Video kenne ich nicht. Das kann sein, dass das mega Cringe
zum Fremdschämen ist. Ich sage es euch nur schon mal. Also bei der Kombination aus den
Dislikes und ausgeschalteten Kommentaren... Fürchte ich, das ist eher zum Fremdschämen.
Aber schauen wir mal. IHK Köln. Also anscheinend eine Eigenproduktion von IHK Köln. Ah, yes.
Erstmal trendige Musik. Die Abmischung von Sound und Stimme ist... Erstmal absolut repräsentativ,
weil wir wissen ja, dass 90% der Auszubildenden in dem Bereich Frauen sind.
Oh, da war ich schon mal. Da war ich schon mal. Also nicht bei dieser Firma, aber hier in
diesem Park oder Park... Da, in diesem Ding, da. Oh. Das Problem ist, wenn ich lauter mache,
ist die Musik zu laut. Die Abmischung sackt, aber ich kann es lauter machen. Morgen. Hallo.
Ich bin heute der Proberazubi. Überhaupt nicht mitgerechnet. Ein absolut nicht null
gestelltes Gespräch. Okay, Moment. Zeig mal her. Was machen die alles? Okay, was haben
wir hier? Time to Act Group. Software Consulting. Okay, da weiß ich mal schon mal was Sache
ist. Was Sache ist. Plut kann ich nicht lesen. Software Consulting. Cloud Pilots kann ich
nicht lesen. Software Consulting. Da wird ja konsultet ohne Ende. Software, die konsulten,
aber ganz schön viel hier, wenn der Tag lang ist. Steht da Big Data? Könnte das sein,
dass da Big Data steht? Wieso hat sie keine Maske auf? Ich glaube, das ist das von 2018.
Da musste man noch keine Maske aufziehen. Oh, by the way. Ich muss in mein Meme Board,
ich muss ein neues Bild machen. Ich habe ein exzellent, ein ganz tolles GIF gefunden
bzw. hat einer auf Twitter. Wo ist das Corona? Hier, Paper Wash. Muss ich hinzufügen. Besser.
Der passt. Der ist in der aktuellen Zeit. Schade, der nix. Die Leute sind immer so glücklich
in diesen Videos. Habt ihr, verspürt ihr das nicht auch, wenn ihr morgens um 5.40 Uhr
aufsteht und zur Arbeit geht? Ja, hallo. Ja, wir sind wieder am Start. Alles toll. Wir
freuen uns so. So viele Mädels. Okay, wie groß sind die? Kannst du mal ins Büro gucken?
Sind schon mal keine Großraumbüros. Das finde ich schon mal gut. Das sind normale Büros.
Oh nein. Der Raum, der wahrscheinlich nur in Werbevideos verwendet wird. Das verwendet
keiner. Das verwendet keiner. Jeder, der sich da dran setzt, sieht sich dem sozialen Druck
ausgesetzt, weil da wahrscheinlich ab und zu mal der Chef durchläuft und sonst was,
warum er jetzt da sitzt und spielt, anstatt zu arbeiten. Das ist einfach nur in Werbevideos
schön. Niemand verwendet das. Welche Playstation ist das überhaupt? Erkennt man das anhand
vom Controller, Leute? Playstation Plus, das ist keine 4er. Das ist eher eine 2er? Was?
Das ist doch keine 4er. Was ist der? Moment, wartet mal kurz. Wartet mal. Ja, tatsächlich,
das ist der 4er. Ich habe gerade den Controller vor mir. Das ist der mit dem Klinkenanschluss
unten. Ja, das ist der 4er. Chat kennt sich aus. Chat hat Ahnung. Warum zeigen die alle
immer ihren Tischfußball? Tischfußballtisch. Ich kenne kaum Leute, die in der IT arbeiten,
die gerne Tischfußball spielen. Mag jetzt nicht repräsentativ sein, aber es zeigen
alle Leute immer ihren Tischfußball, als wäre Tischfußball das einzige Gemeinschaftsding,
was die in IT-Firmen haben. Jedes IT-Unternehmen. Viele IT-Unternehmen haben sowas, weil es
cool aussieht. Viel genutzt von den Mitarbeitern. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das ist ja eigentlich immer
voll, da muss man gucken, dass man noch einen Platz findet. Aber ja, wir fühlen uns hier
auch echt wohl. Und genau, Obst haben wir jede Woche frisch. Das ist gut. Getränke.
Das ist gut. Haben wir hier auch was man möchte. Also kostenlos Obst und Trinken ist ziemlich
gut. Es ist alles komplett frei für die Mitarbeiter. Genau. Und Nahrung fürs Gehirn habt ihr auch
reichlich da. Genau. Einmal der wöchentliche Obstkorb. Da kann man sich auch einfach rausnehmen,
was man möchte. Und ansonsten dahinter versteckt noch ein bisschen das ungesunde. Die ungesunden
Versteckt hinter dem Rohr. Sebaru, dass sie nicht im Alter ist, wo man normalerweise anfängt
als Azubi, das sehe ich auch so. Aber das ist doch für das Video vollkommen wurscht.
Okay, was haben sie denn da? Eine Runde Bananen. Sowohl mal ziemlich abgestandene Gelbe als
auch frische. Was haben wir da sonst noch? Orangen oder so was? Pfirsich? Snackbar.
Das Snackbär. Das ist nicht die Snackbar, das ist der Snackbär. Gratis Snacks. Alles
gut. Ist das hier das Sammelbecken für Geld, wenn es doch was kostet? Also kostenlos, kostenlos
Snacks, Obst und Getränke finde ich schon mal ziemlich gut. Aber es soll ja eigentlich
darum gehen, was man als Fachinformatiker macht, nicht das was an der Firma so geil
ist. Was? PC lustig, neu? Ich sehe das nicht. Ach da, neu. Ach guck mal da steht auch was
es kostet. Ein Snack für 50 Cent. Da steht es kostet was, ist gar nicht umsonst. Das
hier haben wir uns gebadet, das kostet was. Guck mal, da steht drauf was es kostet. Zwei
Snacks für 1,50. Das ist gar nicht umsonst. Deswegen ist das auch voll. Das isst keiner,
würde ich auch nicht machen für 1,50. Was durchaus sein kann, dass die das selbst gar
nicht machen, sondern irgendeinen Dienstleister haben, der das immer auffüllt. Ich bin mir
jetzt gar nicht sicher, hatten die gesagt, dass es umsonst ist? Wenn sie es nicht gesagt
haben, dann bringt es jetzt auch nichts sich darüber zu beschweren, dass es was kostet.
Alles kostenlos, ja ist nicht kostenlos, kostet 1,50. Ach vielleicht ist es auch neu, vielleicht
ist es auch neu, also jetzt ganz neu, dass es 1,50 kostet. Vielleicht hat es ja vorher
nur in Euro gekostet. Obst ist umsonst, ja. Vielleicht ist das Unternehmen Snackbeer.
Wahrscheinlich, lass mal kurz gucken. Snackbeer. Was ist drin im Snackbeer? Tatsächlich, das
kann man sich kaufen. Snackbeer. Da sind sie. Snackbeernaschbox. Frugge, der Frugge Obstkorb.
3 Kilo, das kriege ich ja in einem Monat nicht weg, Alter. Snackbeer. Moment, ich will
keine Probepackung, ich will wissen, was es kostet. Aber ich meine, Testbox bestellen
könnte man schon mal machen, ne? Ach so, sie setzt sich umgehend mit mir in Verbindung,
null. Was kostet es denn? Sie sagen nichts, was es kostet, es ist geheim. Na gut, guck
mal weiter. Ja, und keiner benutzt, keiner wird es benutzen. Es ist ja auch ganz logisch.
Stellt euch mal vor, du sitzt den ganzen Tag da, führst Snacks und spielst Playstation
und dann läuft dein Chef durch. So und dieses Gefühl hast du permanent, deswegen wird es
keiner benutzen. Das steht einfach nur da und sieht cool aus. Das war's. Man kann sich
richtig austoben und einfach die Seele auch ein bisschen baumeln lassen in der Mittagspause.
Supergeil. Wie lang sind Sie schon hier in dem Unternehmen? In der Mittagspause war ich
Pause und ess was. Ja, wir können uns aber auch gerne duzen, weil bei uns generell hier
in der Firma duzen wir uns alle gegenseitig, auch die Geschäftsführung. Das geht so lang,
das geht so lang, bis man mal Meinungsverschiedenheit mit seinem Chef hat. Also je nachdem, wie
weit der Chef oben drüber ist, ist es schwierig. Der eigene Teamleiter ist kein Problem, aber
wenn das dann Abteilungsleiter sonst was wird, da ist das mit dem duzen teilweise hinderlich,
weil man manchmal nicht genau weiß, wie man dann Sachen formulieren soll. Ist bei uns
aber zum größten Teil auch so. Relativ flache Hierarchien aufzuhalten und deswegen genau
ist das allgemeine du. Ach cool, dann bin ich die Xenia. Annika, hallo. Hier haben wir
auch den Hermann. Der Hermann. Sehr gerne, klar, wir duzen uns alle. Sollen wir kurz
hier einfach in den Raum rein? Gerne. Ich kann ja auch mal Fragen stellen. Hermann,
einmal erst Dankeschön, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, direkt mal wie viele Mitarbeiter
hast. By the way, ist es eine Vorstellung von der Firma oder was man als Fachinformatiker
jetzt macht? Also insgesamt sind wir mittlerweile über 400 Mitarbeiter. Davon sind hier in
Köln, in unserem wichtigsten, größten Büro, sind rund 170 Mitarbeiter. Oh wow. Und wie
viele Azubis habt ihr da drunter? Wir haben jetzt gerade nochmal gezählt. Also es sind
genau 40 Mitarbeiter in der Ausbildung und damit halt eben auch fast 10% der Mitarbeiter
in der Ausbildung. Also im Prinzip billige Arbeitskräfte? Nein, wir wollen denen mal
nichts unterstellen. Da sieht man, wie wichtig uns das Thema Ausbildung ist. Auf jeden Fall.
Und sind Fachinformatiker gefragt? Also der Beruf ist ein absoluter Mangelberuf. Wir
haben einen Branchenverband, Bitkom, die haben gerade nochmal gesagt, es fehlen in
Deutschland. Ja, der Bitkom erzählt viel, wenn der Tag lang ist. Bitkom erzählt auch
immer, nein Fachkräftemangel und hier und da und noch mehr Fachkräftemangel und noch
mehr Fachkräftemangel und die Fachkräfte fehlen uns. Was Bitkom immer komplett außer
Acht lässt, ist, dass es vielleicht ja auch sein kann, dass eine Firma zwei Jahre nach
Mitarbeitern sucht, weil sie scheiße sind oder nichts bezahlen wollen oder kacke Arbeitsbedingungen
hat. Also nicht auf die jetzt gemünzt, sondern generell diese Sache mit hohen Fachkräftemangel.
Also ja, es ist aktuell bestimmt nicht so super einfach, aber man muss sich einfach
auch abschminken, dass man super qualifizierte Leute für ein Appel und ein Ei kriegt. Wer
ordentlich bezahlt und wer ordentliche Umstände hat drumherum oder vielleicht auch die ein
oder anderen Vorzüge, da gehen die Leute hin. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Es muss nicht
immer Geld sein. Es kann auch sein, also das Gehalt muss auf jeden Fall stimmen, warum
soll man letztendlich arbeiten, um Geld zu verdienen. Aber es kann auch durchaus andere
Sachen ausschlaggebend sein. Zum Beispiel, wie ist die Anbindung, darf man nicht vergessen.
Eine Firma am Arsch der Welt, wo ich zwei Stunden hinfahre und ein bisschen mehr verdiene,
ist immer für mich schlechter als eine Firma, wo ich in 20 Minuten da bin, vielleicht ein
bisschen weniger verdiene. Leute mit Kindern, wenn es irgendwas mit Unterstützung für Kinderbetreuung,
vielleicht sogar Kinderbetreuung vor Ort gibt, wenn es was Großes ist, mit Sicherheit auch
ein Riesenpluspunkt. Von Kantine im Haus, was auch ein Pluspunkt ist, gibt es einige Sachen,
die für mich ausschlaggebend wären, wenn ich Sachen zur Auswahl hätte.
1000 Mitarbeiter im Bereich IT, also Entwickler, Administratoren, also dramatischer Mangel. Deswegen
ist Ausbildung auch so wichtig. Die Branche ist ohnehin sowieso immer im Wachstum begriffen und
enorm erfolgreich und von daher wird das auch eher zunehmen. Also ich würde mal behaupten,
das ist wahrscheinlich der krisensicherste Job, den man überhaupt in Deutschland hat.
Darauf gebe ich ihm Recht.
Was muss man so mitbringen, wenn man eine Ausbildung starten möchte als Fachinformatiker?
Der Ton sackt, aber ich kann es nicht noch lauter machen, weil vorher...
Also wir sagen, das Wichtigste eigentlich ist Passion, dass man wirklich keine Angst hat vor
IT und IT heißt nicht Blech. Hier macht niemand was mit einem Schraubenzieher oder lötet irgendetwas,
sondern hier geht es darum, intelligente Lösungen zu finden, natürlich viel Softwareentwicklung,
viel Gespräch mit dem Kunden. Das ist etwas, was auch häufig unterschätzt wird,
wie interaktiv man mittlerweile halt eben auch zusammenarbeitet, wie wichtig Kommunikation ist
und man muss die Bereitschaft haben, ständig dazu zu lernen.
Auf jeden Fall. Wusstest du, dass das erste Computerprogramm 1843 von einer Frau entwickelt
wurde? Ne, das wusste ich tatsächlich nicht. Und zwar von Ada Lovelace, also ganz spannend.
Was sagst du dazu? Ist das definitiv auch ein Frauenberuf? Im Grunde ist es eine Schande,
dass wir es in der Branche nicht hinbekommen, diese Quote von, ich glaube rund 13 Prozent Frauenanteil
in einer... Ja, wenn die Mädels nicht wollen, was willst du denn machen? Ich fände es auch gut,
wenn es mehr Frauen gibt, die diesen Beruf ausüben und es sind schon mehr geworden,
aber du kannst ja keinen dazu zwingen. Die Branche über Jahre und wahrscheinlich inzwischen
schon seit 20 Jahren nicht irgendwie haben ändern können. Warum ist das für Frauen ein guter Beruf?
Erstmal ist es eine überraschend kreative Tätigkeit, Stärken, die gerade auch Frauen
oft in hohem Maße mitbringen, wie wir alle wissen. Und es ist dann auch später dann im
Beruf nach der Ausbildung, wenn man mal daran denkt, wie läuft es in der Elternzeit, gibt es
die Möglichkeit im Homeoffice zu arbeiten, kann ich auch einfach mal mit meinem Laptop wo ganz anders
sitzen und arbeiten, habe ich natürlich gerade in der IT-Branche fantastische Möglichkeiten. Aber
es ist, glaube ich, immer noch sehr viel das Bild da, da muss man dann vielleicht wirklich
was mit Hardware schrauben und die unterhalten sich schon seit 12 sind über Grafikkarten,
Performance und Online-Spiele und Ähnliches, aber das hat mit unseren Tätigkeiten hier
natürlich rein gar nichts zu tun. Naja, da macht er sich ein bisschen einfach. Das machen die ja
nicht, weil sie es einfach machen, sondern das machen die Leute, also die Leute unterhalten sich
über Grafikkarten, über Gaming-PCs und sonst was, weil es ein Thema ist, was sie interessiert und
selbstverständlich Leute, die sich zu Technik hingezogen fühlen und sich dafür interessieren,
die ergreifen auch eher so einen Beruf. Also das ist ein bisschen zu kurz gedacht,
das hat damit nichts zu tun. Das ist das, was sie letztendlich dazu geführt hat, so was hier zu
machen. Ja, und außerdem gibt es überhaupt kein Problem, Hardware schrauben ist sehr interessant,
ja. Gerade auch Sachen zusammenlöten und mindestens die gleichen Chancen. Ja, also Mädels,
so geht das nicht. Bewerbt euch. Und was meint ihr, wie viele sich bewerben? Nach wie vor keine. Die
einzige Abteilung bei uns, wo wir wirklich viele Mädels in der IT haben, ist iOS, Apple-Zeugs.
Und die Personalabteilung, aber die Personalabteilung, die zählt ja nicht wirklich zu IT.
Sieht fast aus wie bei uns. Oh nein, das haben sie für das Video hingelegt. Das liegt nur für
das Video da. Das liegt, es hat keinen anderen Grund, dass das da liegt. Das haben die genau
dahingelegt für das Video. Okay, und das Video ist zur Hälfte rum. Wann lernt sie denn mal was,
was man als Fachinformatikerin macht? Also die haben ja echt Spaß hier an der Arbeit. Das kann
man sich sonst nirgendswo so vorstellen, glaube ich. Naja, die Nerf-Katzen sind ja das Geilste
überhaupt. Ich glaube, ich würde jeden Tag meine Kollegen abschießen. Da sieht man mal wieder,
Großraumbüros sind nicht für alles sinnvoll, zum Beispiel für sowas. Das ist ja echt gemütlich
hier. Und hier kann man sich ein bisschen zurückziehen, oder wie? Ja, genau. Also wir
sind ja hier im Großraumbüro und wenn wir gerade telefonieren wollen oder irgendwelche Aufgaben
haben, für die wir gerade ungestört sein wollen, dann hat man hier so ein bisschen Abschottung.
Sag mal, was genau ist denn dein Aufgabenbereich hier bei Time to Act? Also mittlerweile
ist ein Team unter mir, das ich leite und also eine Handvoll an Entwicklern, mit denen ich verschiedene
Applikationen entwickle für unsere Kunden. Ich habe ja damals als auszubildender Fachinformatiker
für Anwendungsentwicklung begonnen. Und was war aber dann damals deine Motivation? Wie wäre es,
wenn ihr euch mal drüber unterhaltet, was der Inhalt von Fachinformatiker ist? Ihr meint,
das ist Azubi für einen Tag Fachinformatiker, darum soll es doch eigentlich gehen.
... speziell als Fachinformatiker zu starten. Ja, ich habe mich halt mit vielen Themen
Richtung Computer beschäftigt, sei es mit Sicherheit oder halt mit Modifizieren von
irgendwelchen Programmen. Es kam dann halt so, dass ich mich bei verschiedenen Firmen beworben
habe und letztendlich bin ich halt, Gott sei Dank, hier gelandet. Hier hat man halt relativ
viel Freiheit und man wird ja hier als Azubi nicht behandelt als ein Azubi. Du wirst immer
als vollwertiger Mitarbeiter wagen. Okay. Schlecht. Man sollte Azubis behandeln als Azubis,
weil Azubis sollen was lernen. Und wenn man Azubis behandelt wie normale Leute,
also nicht wie normale Leute, wie normale Mitarbeiter, heißt das, okay, kommst morgens
hin, sollst dein Zeug machen, ohne dass dir einer was beibringen. Natürlich sollst du dich um
Azubis kümmern wie Azubis. Ich sage damit nicht, du sollst Azubis jetzt, keine Ahnung,
Wasser schicken holen, Wasser gehen holen oder sowas. Sondern du solltest Azubis so behandeln
wie Azubis, weil Azubis müssen was lernen und die sind ja auch gerade deswegen da. Okay,
vielleicht meinen sie das nicht so. Vielleicht meinen sie das nicht so. Vielleicht meinen sie
rein den positiven Aspekt von, so nach dem Motto, Azubis müssen nicht die Kackarbeit machen. Okay,
das ist so. Ja. Übrigens, Phoenix, warum die den Ton so verkacken können, die haben wahrscheinlich
den normalisiert. Die haben nämlich alle, zumindest Mikros, die gehen ja, so ähnlich,
das habe ich ja auch am Start für Technikvideos, die ich nicht mache. Die haben wahrscheinlich
den Normalisierknopf in Vegas nicht gefunden. Dementsprechend hast du auch die gleichen
Möglichkeiten. Das heißt, ich bin schon während der Ausbildung beispielsweise dann mal zwei Wochen
nach Boston zu einem Kunden. Iget. Da wurde mir dann das erste Mal so richtig bewusst, hey,
du bist eigentlich Azubi. Auslands, hör mal auf. Das ist schon was anderes. Hell yeah. Da hätte
ich beispielsweise absolut keinen Bock drauf. Zwei Wochen, als Azubi zwei Wochen in die USA fahren und
da irgendwie, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf. War davon abgesehen, wenn man das gerne macht,
warum nicht? Die zwei Ausbildungen an sich nehmen sich ja normalerweise nicht viel. Das stimmt,
da hat er recht. Die Systemintegration sind mehr so die Leute, die sich mit Hardware beschäftigen,
die die Server aufsetzen, alles das wählen, konfigurieren, alles was dort dazugehört,
das ist jetzt ein bisschen simpel ausgedrückt. Vor allem Netzwerk machen System. Die Leute,
die den Programmcode schreiben und dann nachher die Applikationen entwickeln. Ich kann das Video
nicht lauter machen. Das Problem ist, der Sound ist komplett verkackt in dem Video. Der Sound ist
mal zu laut und mal zu leise. Wenn ich das jetzt lauter mache, dann fliegen euch bei der nächsten
Musik das Ohr weg. Ich kann es mal probieren. Die haben den Sound voll verkackt. Ja, das stimmt,
da hat er recht. Ja, dann danke ich dir, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, mit mir ein bisschen zu
plaudern und ich lasse dich dann hier mal wieder weiter in Ruhe arbeiten. Der ist die Saunamischung.
Was? Was, was, was für ein Ding? Was? Ich habe nichts verstanden.
Hallo Dave. Ich wollte dir kurz Xenia vorstellen. Hi David. Ja, dann lasse ich euch mal alleine.
Viel Spaß. Danke schön. Du machst jetzt eine Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker. Wie kann man
sich das so vorstellen, dass man, wenn man so am Anfang reinkommt in die Ausbildung,
was lernt man da? Ja, am Anfang wird man natürlich erstmal in das Thema reingebracht. Es werden
erstmal grundsätzlich nicht vorausgesetzt, dass man entwickeln kann. Man macht in der
Ausbildung, um es zu lernen und auch den Umgang mit Kunden. Das, das, da hat er vollkommen recht.
Genau. Du brauchst Interesse daran, du musst den Kram nicht alles können. Dafür gibt es ja
die Ausbildung. Ja, richtig. Es wird jetzt nicht erwartet, dass man das schon alles kann. Ja,
es fängt erstmal an mit kleineren Aufgaben. Wie sieht eine Entwicklungsumgebung aus? Womit
entwickelt man? Wie laufen Kundengespräche ab? Wie geht Kundenkontakt? Geh mal weg. Was
man auch dann in der Berufsschule zum Beispiel lernt, bis man dann so eine gewisse Sicherheit in dem
Thema bekommt und auch mal selbstständig, immer mehr anfängt, selbstständig die Themen abzuarbeiten.
Woran arbeitest du gerade? Hast du irgendwie ein spezielles Projekt, das du mir vielleicht auch
zeigen könntest? Ja, habe ich durchaus. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Also das ist erstmal hier so
eine Entwicklungsumgebung. Zeig, zeig. Was ist das? Sieht erstmal alles sehr bunt und verwirrend aus.
Sehr kompliziert vor allem. Mach doch mal scharf. Also erstens ist es Windows. Ist es Windows? Es ist
wahrscheinlich Windows. Ja, es ist Windows 7 noch, wenn ich mir das da oben angucke.
Ist wahrscheinlich Windows 7. Was ist denn das? Ist das Visual Studio? Was ist denn das, was der da hat?
Also stellen es ja nicht scharf. Eclipse? Ja, stimmt. Das kann kein Visual Studio sein. Das Dark
7 funktioniert im Visual Studio besser. Das Eclipse? Ach, keine Ahnung, man erkennt es nicht.
Was denn jetzt auch Eclipse? Ich habe das gar nicht richtig zugeguckt.
Ist das Eclipse? Ja, es ist Eclipse. Es ist Eclipse. Sieht man hier unten. Das ist das
Oldschool Eclipse Symbol. Was macht er denn da? Man sieht es nicht richtig. So, Shep. String, Get Format, Sell, Return, Empty String, Is, Value
Gleich, Gleich, Null. Ja, okay, wir sind ja in Java, da muss das sein. Oder, oder, was ist denn
Sternchen, Sternchen? Ist das überhaupt ein Sternchen? Ist das ein Sternchen? Oder, oder, Sternchen,
Sternchen, Eclipse? Das sieht wahrscheinlich einfach nur aus wie ein Sternchen.
Ah, das ist Quote, Quote. Das ist ein String. Ah, okay, der will gucken, ob das ein Empty String ist.
Mit, mit Leerzeichen entfernen. Ach ja, okay, verstehe. Internet Explorer, Opera, Opera Internet
Explorer, Firefox. Ja, warum? Umso mehr Browser, umso besser. Ja. Am Ende kommt ja ein Produkt
raus. Herausragend, Twitch Prime. Exzellent Subscription. Dankeschön. Hier dann unten
zum Beispiel fange ich halt an, hier was, wie in einem Texteditor. Das ist ein Texteditor.
Und dann kann ich hier einfach loslegen. Wie in einem Texteditor. Das ist ein Texteditor.
Da eingibst, wird dann umgesetzt in eben das Endprodukt. Ah, jetzt sieht man mal was. Okay,
also, was machen wir denn, oh, was machen wir denn schön? Also, den Kamerafokus hätte man auch mal
ein bisschen schöner machen können, er kennt ja quasi gar nichts. Ist Empty. Das ist doch garantiert schon
eingebaut, oder? Hat, hat die, hat die Standard, die Standard Java String Klasse kein irgendwie
ist Empty oder sowas? Ja, ist eingebaut. Es hätte mir nämlich auch sehr gewundert, wenn das
nicht eingebaut wäre, weil sowas ist so ein Standard Ding. Schau mal, ob die Namen ist
irgendwas mit Exzell. Exzell Data Java. Ja. Auf Null kann man nicht mit Equals Prüf, das stimmt.
Das ist richtig. Aber man könnte erst Null checken und dann Equals machen. Ist auch egal.
So, wir machen mal, wir machen mal kurz weiter. Ich muss da kurz was gucken. Es fließt dann mit ein.
Also, die Funktion selber lässt sich an Code immer recht schwer beschreiben. Das ist ein bisschen
so ein Eisberg. Man sieht nur die Spitze. Aber der Programm Code drunter ist eigentlich...
By the way, das ist was, was mich übelst triggert immer, wenn das, wenn das, wenn das Leute bei mir
machen, wenn ich... Aber ihr wisst, ich hab's mit special-männlichen Sachen ja nicht so.
Wenn jemand neben mir steht und macht die Hand auf meinen Stuhl, da fühlt man sich so bedrängt
immer. Ich mag das überhaupt nicht. Das ist ein bisschen so wie in der Schule, wenn der Lehrer
rumgelaufen ist und hat von hinten über dich auf das Blatt geguckt, was du gerade schreibst.
Die eigentliche treibende Kraft.
Ich hab mich ja heute so ein bisschen drauf vorbereitet und ein bisschen geschaut, was ist überhaupt
Coding und Programmiersprachen und alles. Aber ich muss sagen, es gibt doch viel, viel mehr, was man wissen muss.
Ach, wer hatte das gedacht, wenn man sich zwei Drittel des Videos den Pausenraum anguckt und von
der Personalabteilungsfrau rumführen lässt, dass man keine Ahnung hat, was man eigentlich als Fachanwalt gemacht.
Für die Menschen, die dann wirklich einen Durchblick haben und wissen, was sie da überhaupt tun.
Okay.
Wo ist der Ball? Ah, da ist der Ball. Okay, es ist ein Ball drin, das ist kein Fake gewesen.
Oh nein!
Ich bin direkt vor die Füße gerollt.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Macht ihr eigentlich öfter sowas, dass ihr euch dann noch nach dem Job noch mal trefft?
Ja, also wir haben jede Woche offiziell alle zwei Wochen ein Azubi-Meeting, wo wir alle Azubis zusammenkommen,
irgendwelche offiziellen Themen besprechen, Vorträge halten und wir planen auch dann Events.
Zum Beispiel das Azubi-Essen. Das findet viermal pro Jahr statt, pro Quartal einmal.
Und dann stellt uns die Firma... Ich seh die die ganzen Tage, warum muss ich mit denen noch essen gehen?
Das steht zur Verfügung, wo wir dann entsprechend essen gehen können.
Cool, das heißt also Team-Building-Maßnahmen gibt es hier auf jeden Fall reichlich.
Was macht ihr denn an der Ausbildung besonders Spaß?
Ja, am meisten Spaß macht mir definitiv das Programmieren selber, gerade wenn man da neue Projekte hat
und einfach was Neues ausprobieren kann.
Ich bin wahnsinnig überzeugt.
Und sich dabei auch selber immer wieder verbessert und man auch ständig diesen Aha-Affekt hat, so ach, so funktioniert das.
Und das Beste ist dann, wenn man dann zum Schluss hingeht und sieht, es funktioniert.
Alles klar, wollen wir dann noch ne Runde?
Noch ne Runde.
Oh, ist das... Du scheiß aus dem Fail-Video, Alter.
Okay, die sind immer noch nicht fertig.
So, ich bin jetzt wieder draußen.
Ehrlich gesagt wäre ich gerne noch ein bisschen länger da geblieben, denn mir hat das heute richtig viel Spaß gemacht.
Ja, du hast ja auch nichts gemacht.
Ich hätte niemals gedacht, dass die Welt der Nullen und Einsen so abwechslungsreich sein könnte.
Ich hoffe, ihr hattet auch Spaß und konntet einen guten Einblick in den Beruf des Fachinformatikers bzw. der Fachinformatikerin bekommen.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, dann lasst mir gerne ein Like da oder einen Kommentar.
Der Fachkraft für Informationstechnologie, bitteschön. Wir müssen das möglichst generell halten.
Und falls ihr noch Fragen habt oder vielleicht sogar direkt mit einer Ausbildung starten wollt, dann meldet euch bei der IHK Köln.
Ich werde was und ihr hoffentlich auch.
Okay, das ist ganz ehrlich, das Video hätte mir, wenn ich auf der Suche nach einem Ausbildungsplatz gewesen wäre und ich nicht wüsste, was ich machen will, absolut nichts gebracht.
Er hat mir null gebracht.
Außer, dass ich wüsste, dass es bei denen kostenloses Obst und Trinken gibt.
Was wird uns der sonst noch empfohlen?
Millionär werden, bevor du 30 bist. Klar, nur mit diesem YouTube Video, easy, kein Problem.
Es werden jetzt 1,4 Millionen Leute, bevor sie 30 sind, Millionär. Easy, gar kein Problem.
Fachinformatiker in Fachsystem mit Ausbildung BIMAS. Was ist denn was zum Teufel ist BIMAS?
Bundesamt für Arbeit und Soziales. Oh, das klingt sinnvoll, ja.
Unzuverlässige, darf jetzt ProSieben natürlich nicht fehlen.
Der schraubt ja an Hardware. Ich denke, es wird nicht an Hardware geschraubt, hat er gerade erzählt.
Der schraubt an Hardware, stellt euch mal vor. Was ist das für ein antikes Telefon?
Das ist von 1985, er hat angerufen. Ok, das ist von 2017. Aber auch 2017 waren Rechner mit Doppel-PS2 nicht mehr so verbreitet.
Windows-Installation, exzellent. Bei Honeypot sind auch gute Dokus über Vue.js Entwickler.
Schickbar, aber auch nur, wenn der Cringe-Faktor ein bisschen da ist.
Das sieht aus, wie einer, der beim Media-Markt arbeitet.
Ja, anscheinend. Ah, das ist so ein Druckerpatron-Tausch-Ausbildung.
So sieht die Realität für Service-Mitarbeiter übrigens nicht aus.
Die Realität für Service-Mitarbeiter sieht eher so aus, dass er jetzt angeschissen wird, dass er entweder zu langsam ist.
Was er dann eigentlich will, dass es jetzt nicht geht, weil er gerade wichtige Sachen machen muss.
Warum es überhaupt kaputt geht und warum, was auch immer.
Genau, Original-Quote, ganz bestimmt.
Oh Mann.
Ich glaube, ob das irgendjemand Bock auf die Ausbildung gemacht hat, wage ich ja zu bezweifeln.
Ausbildung im Test. Was machen die da alle?
Eine Fachinformatikerin für Systemintegration. Was machen die überhaupt? Unser Job-Tester hat es herausgefunden.
Hallo, ich bin der Dominik. Ich würde heute gerne mehr erfahren über den Beruf als Fachinformatiker.
Das ist unser Azubi-Büro. Wir sind immer drei neue Auszubildende.
Azubi-Büro. Okay, das heißt, man hat nichts, oder was?
Systemintegration ist, wie der Name schon sagt, du installierst irgendwelche Systeme,
virtuelle Maschinen aufsetzen, Betriebssysteme installieren. Auch den Benutzerservice gibt's, der sich um die ganze Hardware kümmert.
Hallo, wir kommen um die Kommunikationssoftware einzurichten. Wir haben jetzt hier die Webcam und das Headset.
What the fuck?
Warum bauen die alle nur irgendwelche Jammer-Plätze auf?
Und singt alles? Ja, hier funktioniert das Headset.
Hast du Informatik? Ja. Auf welcher Schule bist du? In der Realschule Neusses.
Auch in Neusses? Da war ich auch. Cool.
Also in Informatik, bei uns in der Schule, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Informatik hieß,
haben wir Word-Vorlagen lila gemacht, weil es unser Lehrer toll fand.
Das hab ich schon ein paar Mal erzählt. Du musstest einfach deine Powerpoint-Sache oder dein Word,
musstest du einfach lila machen, dann hat er sich gefreut, leila, leila, leila, und hast da eins gekriegt.
Also, was ich an meiner Ausbildung hier bei LED gut finde, ist, dass wir halt alle drei...
Wenn die heißen LED, hat er gerade gesagt LED? Ich hoffe, mit RGB.
... alle drei Monate in der anderen Abteilung, alle drei Monate, wenn man hier bei LED gut findet, ist...
Ach, LEW, nicht LED.
... alle drei Monate in der anderen Abteilung sind, dass du einfach diesen Rundumblick hast,
was man in der IT alles möglich ist, was man da alles machen kann.
Ich bin eher hier in der Ausbildung, um wirklich was zu lernen.
Das ist bei der LEW schon ein großer Pluspunkt, dass du...
Okay, na gut, das ist ein Film von LEW für... Da kann man ein bisschen Werbung machen.
Die wollen ja auch, dass die Leute zu ihnen gehen.
Ordentlicher Drucker.
Das finden die Leute immer cool.
Das habe ich auch immer gemacht mit Leuten, die Praktikum gemacht haben,
oder die mal einen Tag so Schnupperdings gemacht haben, oder die sich für die Ausbildung interessiert haben.
Mit denen bin ich auch immer durchs Rechenzentrum gelaufen.
Das kam immer gut an, das fanden die alle geil.
Geil.
Das ist ja voll schwer.
Wie schwer das geht. Ja, das meint man gar nicht.
Und dann zum Schluss haben wir dann noch...
Okay, Mitchellbox4M.
Linux ausprobiert.
Das ist gut, das ist gut.
Und was man da mit alles machen kann.
Ja Dominik, du hattest jetzt ja einen Abwechsel.
Ich hoffe, er hat in 5 Minuten mal alles gemacht, was man mit Linux machen kann.
Ja, aber nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Also ganz ehrlich, besser, auch weil ich jetzt ein bisschen geflamet habe, weiß ich aber nicht,
böse gemeint, besser als das IHK-Video.
Und man kriegt so ungefähr ein Gespür für was man macht.
Einzige Sache, wo ich persönlich absolut Abneigung dagegen habe und auch niemals machen würde,
ist Endkundensupport.
Sei es jetzt im Haus oder Hotline oder sonst was.
Das würde ich mir im Leben nicht geben, da könnte ich mir sonst was für bezahlen.
Der Witz ist ja, dass gerade die Jobs auch noch nicht gut bezahlt sind.
Aber die könnten mir extrem viel Geld dafür bezahlen.
Endkundensupport würde ich nicht ertragen, tagtäglich zu machen.
Das funktioniert gar nicht.
Es ist halt ganz anders, als ich es mir vorgestellt habe.
Nämlich, man ist halt jeden Tag woanders und man macht auch immer unterschiedliche Sachen.
Und ich könnte mir das schon gut vorstellen als Job.
Wäre der Job auch was für dich, alle Infos findest du hier.
Oh man, so genug gekockt, reicht ja.
Genug für Informatiker-Zeug.
Ah man.
Also das IHK-Video war wirklich nicht gut.
Pragmatik, Lu, Dankeschön für das, aber was?
Check mal ZIP Call I.O.
Kenn ich nicht.
Free browser-based video calling.
Oh ja.
Warum nicht, oder?
Mit WebRTC ist sowas ja heute glücklicherweise zum größten Teil eingebaut im Browser.
CSLSM sagt, ich bin aktuell im First Second Level nach der Ausbildung, habe aber jetzt gekündigt.
Excellent.
Also First Level, das würde ich eh nicht aushalten auf Dauer.
Ja, dass der das hosten kann, wenn es P2P ist, ist klar.
Da geht da kaum was über den Server außer Signaling.
Weil WebRTC ist es ja auch so.
Also so ein WebRTC-Video-Chat zu programmieren, ist eine Sache von, also ich dachte jetzt nicht, dass das easy ist, was er gemacht hat.
Ich habe es mir nicht angeguckt, ja.
Es ist eine Sache von einer halben Stunde, du musst nur das Signaling über den Server machen, das braucht kaum was.
Was ist First und Second Level?
Das ist so eine Einteilung, quasi, ähm, wie, wo, wo die Leute aufschlagen, ja.
Du schlägst erstmal, wenn du bei der Hotline anrufst, ähm, schlägst du erstmal beim First Level auf.
Die gucken dann, ok, bist du hier richtig?
Schauen vielleicht auch, in welche Kategorie gehört das, was du gemeldet hast?
Und dann leiten sie das weiter zum Second Level, der guckt dann.
Ok, wo liegt dann genau der Fehler? Und irgendwann, äh, wird dann festgestellt, oh, das ist ein Bug.
Und dann landest du beim Third Level, der sich dann darum kümmert, den Bug zu beheben.
So, so ganz grob, so die Theorie.
Aber die Einteilung, finde ich, hat über die letzten Jahre abgenommen.
Habe ich jetzt die letzten Jahre weniger gehört, diese ganze Second Level, First Level, Third Level Geschichte?
Äh, der Umut sagt, bei mir sieht es nicht anders aus. Muss immer Workstations zusammenbauen und aufbauen, dann über die GPU zuweisen.
Auch, das klingt Resident Sleeper, Alter.
Was ist der Last Level?
Der Twitch Chat ist der Last Level.
Also bei uns ist es ein bisschen, äh, ein bisschen anders.
Also bei uns, der First Level, also als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe, war der First Level diejenigen, die dann eine Mail geschrieben haben.
Also jemand hat angerufen, hat gesagt, es geht was nicht, oder hat eine Mail geschrieben, es geht was nicht.
Dann haben die einfach eine Mail-Vorlage aufgemacht.
Unser Techniker arbeitet mit Hochdruck an der Lösung des Problems und haben es weitergeleitet.
Das war das, was der First Level gemacht hat.
Ja, das war es zum größten Teil.
Da haben aber auch wirklich Leute gesessen, die von Technik absolut keinen Plan hatten.
Der Mädelsanteil im First Level war relativ hoch.
Ich sage einfach nur, wie es ist. Ich sage nicht, dass es gut oder schlecht ist.
Muss man ja heute immer Disclaimer dabei sagen.
Oder, dass Mädels das nicht können würden.
Im First Level waren relativ viele Mädels, weil da ging es einfach darum, dass du gut mit Leuten telefonieren konntest.
Und in der reinen Technik-Abteilung waren relativ wenig Mädels.
Das war zumindest die Einteilung bei uns.
Soziale Sachen können Mädels einfach meistens besser, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Also mit Leuten telefonieren und Sachen so verkaufen, dass sich der Kunde nicht rüber aufregt.
Das können Mädels ganz gut.
Es gibt auch genug Mädels, die super technische Sachen können, aber bei uns war es eben umgedreht.
Viele Mädels im First Level, wenig Mädels in der Technik.
Ich finde es schlimm, dass man heute immer noch so einen Disclaimer dranhauen muss.
Nach dem Motto, dass man es gar nicht falsch verstehen kann.
Hier ist ein First Level, das kenne ich.
Wir haben doch schon mal so ein Video geguckt vom First Level-Mitarbeiter.
Aber der war von einem Operation-Typ, haben wir mal ein Video geguckt.
Der dann auch nachts Rundgang gemacht hat und sowas.
So, was haben wir als nächstes? 10 Mythen über das Darknet.
Der Chiller, ein Lego Snowblower.
Okay, das müssen wir uns mal kurz angucken.
Der Typ ist geil, was der immer baut.
Ja, genau, das haben wir uns schon angeguckt, Nullenhart.
Das war ganz gut.
Nach 2 Monaten ist der Hof dann auch geräumt.
Jetzt wird geblowt, Leute.
Das ist geil.
Heute sagt man, ich feiere diese Lego-Videos.
Aber ich finde es cool.
Lange Aushalten, also lange lange das Durchfahren wird es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Und es braucht 3 Monate für den Hof, aber cool ist es.
Oh, da wird er reingefahren hier.
Oh, gleich verreckt es.
Es kommt kaum noch vorwärts, habt ihr das gesehen?
Ich wusste bis vor 2 Jahren gar nicht, dass das Wort überhaupt gibt.
Jetzt weiß ich, dass das überhaupt existiert.
Und habe noch keine Lösung dafür.
Also, eine ultimative Lösung gibt es nicht.
Aus meiner Sicht gibt es 2 Sachen, die man machen muss.
Erstens, Glück haben, dass man Sachen machen kann, die einen interessieren.
Oder was heißt Glück haben?
Man kann es ja auch beeinflussen.
Sachen machen, die einen wirklich interessieren.
Dann ist man da prinzipiell interessierter.
Und das nächste ist, man muss sich damit abfinden,
dass man keine 8 Stunden voll konzentriert arbeiten kann.
Das geht nicht, das kann niemand.
Und Leute, die das behaupten, die erzählen Mist.
Wenn du es nur schaffst, eine halbe Stunde was zu machen, ist vielleicht schlecht.
Aber 8 Stunden am Stück konzentriert arbeiten geht nicht.
3-4 Stunden vielleicht, aber auch nicht am Stück,
über den Tag verteilt, konzentriert arbeiten.
Der Rest muss ja auch nicht total unsinnig sein.
Da wird dann irgendwelche Sachen gemietet.
Oder es werden irgendwelche retrospektiven Sachen geschrieben.
Oder irgendwas, wo man sich nicht so wahnsinnig konzentrieren muss.
Aber mehr als 3-4 Stunden über den Arbeitstag verteilt,
wenn man wirklich Sachen machen muss,
wo man sich extrem konzentrieren muss auf Probleme.
Kann man zwar versuchen, oder kann man sich zwar zu zwingen,
aber die Ergebnisse werden immer schlechter mit der Zeit.
Ja.
Dein Ausbilder ist IT-Kaufmann.
Ja, da kann man leider nichts machen, ne?
Dann hat er wahrscheinlich, ich weiß nicht,
wie sehr sich IT-Kaufmänner mit der eigentlichen Technik auskennen.
Aber überall, wo BWL-Zeug drin steckt, ist er meistens eher heiße Luft verbreitet.
Die Corona-App hat angeblich 10 Millionen Downloads.
Ja, ist doch gut.
Ich kann es nicht verwenden, weil es auf meinem Smartphone nicht läuft.
Außerdem gehe ich eh nicht raus.
Brauche ich keine Corona-App.
Einfach drinnen sitzen bleiben, easy.
Babyhühnchen, ja, das kann ich voll und ganz nachvollziehen.
Es sind Tage, wo wirklich 8 Stunden am Stück anstrengend ist.
Und da habe ich dann auch keinen Bock mehr,
irgendwas Großartiges zu machen.
Es ist halt auf Dauer belastend,
wenn das wirklich die Regel ist als die Ausnahme.
Weil ansonsten hast du halt das Problem,
und das hatte ich ja auch schon gerade,
wo ich noch bei dem alten Arbeitgeber war.
Da hast du dann Tage, du machst nichts,
du gehst im Prinzip auf die Arbeit, hast dann gearbeitet,
und dann hast du keinen Bock, was zu machen, gehst ins Bett.
Das ist halt scheiße, wenn man sich dann einfach mal überlegt,
man würde das jetzt sein ganzes Leben lang machen,
da hast du ja absolut nichts von.
Das war auch übrigens einer der Gründe, warum ich gesagt habe,
okay, jetzt, wo ich ein bisschen Kohle nebenbei verdiene,
reduziere ich meine Arbeitszeit.
Und das bringt wirklich was.
Ich kann es jedem nur empfehlen,
4 Tage in der Woche statt 5 Tage zu arbeiten.
Das Gehalt ist nicht so viel weniger,
also nicht so sehr, dass man es großartig merkt,
weil man ist absolut jetzt schon komplett am Limit,
wo man nicht mit weniger auskommt, dann nicht.
Ich habe montags frei.
Also es ist erstens nicht so viel weniger Geld,
und ich habe halt jetzt montags frei, das heißt,
ich habe dann quasi ab Freitag Mittag,
Freitags gehe ich dann meistens auch 13 Uhr,
wenn ich auf die Arbeit gehe, Freitag 13 Uhr,
bis quasi Dienstag morgens habe ich,
oder bis Freitags abends quasi, habe ich dann frei.
Ein Tag mehr macht richtig viel aus.
Das führt dazu, dass das Wochenende quasi 100% erholsamer ist
und man 100% mehr geschafft kriegt,
weil normalerweise ist es so, wenn du Freitags heimkommst,
vor allem wenn du Freitag noch den ganzen Tag geschafft hast,
kommst du Freitag heim und machst nichts mehr,
du bist kaputt.
So, Samstag musst du dann irgendwelche Sachen machen,
die du vielleicht schon hättest machen müssen, sei es nur einkaufen.
Und außerdem musst du Samstag erst mal dich ein bisschen ausruhen von der Woche,
okay, dann musst du Sachen machen, die du halt machen musst,
und dann hast du nach dem Nachmittag noch ein bisschen Zeit,
eventuell bist du dann auch schon wieder müde,
weil du dich noch nicht richtig ausgeruht hast.
Samstag machst du auch jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
Sonntag ist der einzige Tag, wo du eigentlich von morgens bis abends machen kannst,
was du willst.
Allerdings, Sonntag Nachmittag denkt man dann schon wieder dran,
ah fuck, ich muss mich jetzt ja irgendwie schon fertig machen,
weil ich Montag morgens wieder aufstehen muss.
So, und, ähm, diese, diese, ähm,
dieser eine Tag mehr, Montag führt dazu,
dass das gesamte Wochenende, inklusive Montag lustigerweise,
viel stressfreier ist.
Und mich juckt es dann auch überhaupt,
also seit ich nur noch vier Tage arbeite,
juckt es mich auch überhaupt nicht mehr,
dass ich montags abends dran denke,
ich muss jetzt wieder arbeiten gehen,
weil erstens weiß ich, okay, es sind ja nur vier Tage, in Anführungsstrichen,
äh, und außerdem weiß ich ja, ich bin jetzt,
ich, ich, ich konnte jetzt genug machen von dem, was ich wollte,
äh, ich bin jetzt ausgeruht,
und, ähm, dann schocken mich die nächsten vier Tage auch nicht mehr.
Also, ich kann es wirklich jedem nur empfehlen,
der nicht komplett am Limit mit der Kohle ist,
und das nicht, sich nicht leisten kann, ein bisschen weniger zu verdienen.
Vier Tage statt fünf Tage ist das Beste, was man machen kann.
Äh, Sascha Hemy, keine Ahnung,
mit Samorin Forms hab ich noch nie was gemacht.
Äh, iOS hat da aber Probleme,
was, ähm, äh, Sideloading und sowas angeht,
mit Apps, die verfallen nach einer Woche dann.
Ja, genau.
Äh, sieben, man kann irgendwie nur für sieben Tage Sideloaden.
Killt das nicht deine Rente?
Nö.
Also, erstens ist die, ist die Rente,
die ich quasi von, vom Staat dann kriege,
wenn ich in Rente gehe, eh nicht so der Bringer.
Ähm, dazu hab ich noch ne private, äh, ne, keine private,
ne, ne, ne, ne, betriebliche Altersvorsorge abgeschlossen,
die hab ich aber auch nur gemacht,
weil, äh, das Hälfte, Hälfte ist,
und sich deswegen lohnt.
Ähm, da krieg ich ganz gut was,
und außerdem hab ich noch relativ viel Kohle
auf der hohen Kante und ein Haus.
Also, insofern, ich glaube nicht,
dass ich so die Probleme im Alter kriegen werd.
Ich muss das ehrlich sagen,
ich hab eh nicht vor, bis 67 zu arbeiten.
Äh, glaubst du, drei Tage arbeiten
wäre dann wieder zu langweilig?
Nö.
Man kann immer, man kann immer was machen,
wenn man Hobbies hat,
wenn man sich für Sachen interessiert.
Ich hab auch schon, ich hab jetzt ja auch in letzter Zeit öfters
überlegt, ob ich nicht nur drei Tage arbeiten sollte,
aber, ähm, ich hab keinen Bock mich drum zu kümmern.
Da kommt wieder das bei mir zum Tragen,
dass ich eigentlich zu faul bin,
mich um Sachen zu kümmern,
auch wenn sie für mich nicht schlecht werden.
Wie viele Stunden? Ja, ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
30 oder 32 oder so.
30, 31,5.
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Äh, Luko sagt, ich überlege,
um auf vier Tage zu wechseln.
Das kann ich, wie gesagt, wenn du nicht gerade jetzt schon am Limit bist,
was Geld anbelangt, kann ich das nur empfehlen.
Es ist nicht so viel weniger Geld.
Und, ähm,
letztendlich, was hat man davon?
Was hat man davon, wenn man
die ganze Zeit arbeitet
und nichts, äh,
nichts sonst mehr machen kann?
Die wenigsten Leute, glaube ich,
wenn die irgendwann mal abkratzen
und sich so Gedanken machen, ja, wie war ihr Leben so?
Ich sag, kaum einer von denen
wird je sagen, oh, hätte ich mal mehr gearbeitet.
Keiner. Die sagen alle, oh, hätte ich mal mehr mit der Familie gemacht,
hätte ich mal weniger gearbeitet,
hätte ich mal das gemacht, sonst was.
Kaum einer wird sagen, oh, fuck, ich hätte noch mehr arbeiten sollen.
So, und jetzt seid ihr ja auch noch in einem Alter,
wo es sich lohnt, ja. Jetzt könnt ihr noch Sachen machen.
Also nicht so wie ich,
der den ganzen Tag dann auch nichts anderes macht,
außer hier streamen und ein paar Sachen spielen,
Zeug programmieren und sonst, wenigstens mach ich das,
worauf ich Bock hab, ja.
Ähm, gibt ja durchaus Leute, die wollen mal
irgendwo hinfahren. Die würden sagen, ey,
ich würd gern mal
meine Kohle nehmen
und irgendwo anders hinfliegen oder so.
Ja, ich glaub, 7 Stunden 48 pro Tag, ja.
Ich finde es interessant, dass der Twitch-Chat
besser weiß, wie viel Arbeitszeit ich hab als, ähm,
als ich selbst.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch für Videos hier am Start?
xD hätte mehr Max-FPS-Streams geguckt.
Der streamt doch gar nicht.
Ich kenn, ich kenn nur den Wublaws.
Gesetzliche Rente kann man komplett vergessen.
Das ist voll fürn Arsch.
Die, ähm...
Gesetzliche Rente wird ja eh,
wenn, wenn ich mal in Rente gehe
und vor allem, wenn ihr mal in Rente geht,
ist das noch schlimmer. Ihr seid ja noch mal 10 Jahre jünger im Durchschnitt,
würd ich mal sagen, wenn's reicht.
Also ich, wie gesagt, spiel jetzt 35.
Wahrscheinlich sind die meisten hier, wenn's hochkommt, mal 25.
Die wird ja noch schlechter.
Da kannst du gar nichts mehr großartig mit anfangen.
Was übrigens ein richtig großes Problem wird.
Auch die ganzen Rentenversicherungen, wo sie, ähm,
die letzten Jahre so hinterher waren,
dass die Leute das abschließen sollten,
ob die überhaupt ausbezahlt werden,
da hab ich auch so meine Zweifel.
Weil, überlegt euch mal.
Jetzt, in diesen Jahren,
in den letzten Jahren,
jetzt, in diesen
Jahrgängen,
bezahlen die Leute im Endeffekt nur ein.
Es braucht kaum, also aktuell
geht kaum einer in Rente,
der privat irgendwie seine Rentenversicherung
vorgesorgt hat.
So. Und die
aktuell kriegen die ganzen
Versicherungen, was Rentenversicherungen angeht,
quasi nur Einnahmen. Und dann
wird in 20 Jahren, 15,
20 Jahren, wird auf einen Schlag
einfach mal Millionen
Leute ihre private,
ihre Rentenversicherung
Geld haben wollen.
Ob das so sicher
ist, wie getan wird, hab ich so meine Zweifel.
Weil wir haben jetzt seit den letzten Jahren
schon gesehen, dass sich da auch mal ganz gerne verkalkuliert wird.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich die
private, äh, nicht die private, die betriebliche
Rentenversicherung, äh, Renten, Renten,
Altersvorsorge gemacht hab, ist, weil
Hälfte der Arbeitgeber was bezahlt, was er sonst
nicht bezahlen würde. Also das Geld würde das uns einfach behalten.
Das ist gut, deswegen
hab ich das gemacht. Ansonsten
würde ich, würde ich das wahrscheinlich auch nicht machen.
Nochmal Battlefield,
äh, Lego und Battlefield.
Wir gucken uns jetzt eine Runde
Battlefield Top Plays an. Und danach
gucken wir uns das an, das ist, das ist, oder das,
das sind beides, äh, Big, Big Brain.
Ne, wir gucken uns den Hardest Speedrun Trick an.
Das ist ein geiles Video. Also
ein geiles Video vom,
wie krass die Leute mittlerweile in dem Game
sind, aber wirklich übertrieben gut.
Äh, Kusswort haben wir glaube ich sogar schon mal.
Alter, guckt euch das mal an.
Alter, wie der abgeht.
Gibt's den überhaupt noch?
Sorry, gibt's sie überhaupt noch?
Lange nichts mehr von gehört.
Alter, die Leute sind wirklich gut,
was die Inputs angeht.
Bitte, bitte noch schneller vorspulen, dass man auch genau versteht, was passiert.
What?
What the fuck?
Was passiert da?
Alles klar, easy.
Was zum Teufel ist parallel?
Ach, das ist diese Geschichte mit Koordinaten
in Mario 64, ne?
Dass die Welt von Mario 64
quasi mehrfach vorhanden ist, wenn die Koordinaten
irgendwie über, äh, overflowen oder so.
Na, wenn man schon mal Luigi heißt, dann ist auch alles klar,
was man machen muss. Mario Speedrun.
Huge.
What the fuck?
Spare the beast, 12 Mona, danke schön.
Für den Sub, huge subscription.
Was passiert da eigentlich gerade?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ja, das kenn ich.
Das geht?
Wir haben es geschafft!
Ja!
Zeig mal.
Also wenn du schon mal, wenn du schon mal, ähm,
Slowdown machen musst,
dass du überhaupt alles erkennst,
da weißt du, dass die Kacke am Dampfen ist, ey.
Okay, alles klar.
Alles klar.
Äh, die, die spielen, die spielen auf 64.
Was?
Man darf nicht vergessen, das macht er alles am Stück,
ohne dass das irgendwie zusammengeschnitten ist,
ohne dass da irgendwie save states dazwischen sind oder sonst was.
Das macht er alles am Stück und das Heftigste kommt da noch.
Alles klar.
Wo ist die Bombe hin?
Ach du Scheiße!
Das wäre schlecht.
Äh, äh, weil der Chat, ich habe es bei ein paar Leuten im Chat schon gesehen,
sie fragen sich wie man so Klitsches rauskriegt.
Äh, bei Mario 64 ist es einfach so, dass sehr viele Leute
sich das Game permanent ausprobieren und Sachen versuchen herauszubekommen.
Und das Game ja auch schon 20 Jahre oder so alt ist oder irgendwie so in dem Dreh.
Das hat eine Weile gedauert.
Ich meine, das sind ja nicht neue Sachen, das sind ja relativ neue Sachen.
Hast du den netten Battlefield Next Gen Teaser gesehen? Nee?
Krass.
Ey, das Ganze, das Ganze gucken wir uns jetzt nochmal in Echtzeit an.
Ja, 55 Sekunden geht das eigentlich nur. Guckt euch mal an, wie krass der Typ drauf ist, äh.
Alles klar. So, und jetzt kommt ja der schwierige Teil erst noch.
Alles am Stück, ohne zu schneiden, ohne Save States, ohne sonst was.
Das ist übelst heftig.
Guckt euch mal an. Ach du Kacke.
Und wie gesagt, das ist kein Emulator, das ist auf dem N64 erspielt.
Das heißt, das könnt ihr auch machen.
Wenn ihr es denn könnt.
Okay, was? Battlefield Video, äh, Stellzone, neun Monate. Excellent Subscription.
Ähm, was sollen wir gucken? Battlefield Next Gen.
Das da? Nee. Das da.
Da hat er recht, optisch und soundmäßig sind die Spiele immer extrem gut, dafür waren die letzten Battlefield Spiele als Spiele, naja.
Ich weiß nicht, wie tief Jack-Frags noch bei EA im Bombe steckt, keine Ahnung, wie das aktuell so ist.
Und texturierte Soldiers.
Moment, das war alles?
Das war alles, darüber mach ich jetzt ein 10 Minuten Video, okay.
Wait a minute, das ist doch genau das gleiche, was Jack-Frags auch erzählt hat.
Moment, der hat einfach den Kram vorgelesen, was die erzählt hat.
Was hat der Kram vorgelesen?
Okay, das Video ist ja aber voll für'n Arsch.
Ich meine, man kann über 10 Sekunden viel länger philosophieren, kann man jetzt ja wohl nicht mehr.
Schauen wir uns jetzt mal die Battlefield Top Plays an.
Das ist Mittag, oh ja, ich hab Hunger.
Alter, da werden sie weggesprayt.
Wann gibt's mal wieder ein Video, bald.
Commentary lass ich mal ein bisschen leiser, das sag ich jedes Mal das gleiche.
Das wird wieder sein.
Das ist doch kein Konsolenclip.
Das ist ein Konsolenclip, echt? Ja, das ist ein Konsolenclip.
Dafür ist es aber echt gut.
Ach klar, es ist ein Konsolenclip, das fällt mir nur nicht so auf, weil es so dunkel ist, aber der Motionplern die Auflösung.
Metro? Ist das Metro, was ist das für ne Map?
Die sind ja blöde, wie sie wieder reinrennen.
Na, Metro, was sonst.
Was ist mit den Gegnern wieder los?
Alter.
Oh.
Ja.
MP7. Nee, ist gar keine MP7, ist MPX.
Ich mag Kaka, Top Name im Chat wieder, sagt es kann ihm keiner erzählen, dass es nicht teilweise gestellt ist.
Ich glaube auch, dass manche Sachen in den Clips manchmal mit ein bisschen zu viel Glück sind.
Gerade die Helis, die teilweise direkt in Raketen reinfliegen.
RIP.
Battlefield 3.
Was genau hat noch mal der Schalldämpfer in Battlefield 3 gebracht? War das sinnvoll, einen Schalldämpfer zu verwenden?
Ich kann mich da gar nicht mal richtig dran erinnern.
Die checken wieder gar nichts, Alter. Ah, der hat was kapiert, okay.
Am besten war Kid Switch in Bad Company 2. Du bist rübergelaufen, zack, hast das Kid am Start gehabt.
Nice.
Die Shotguns sind teilweise so und so verlässlich.
Aimen ist overrated. Wird nicht geaimt.
Smoke. Doch kein Smoke.
Ja, das passiert. Bazaar ist eine ziemlich gute Map, 16 vs. 16, aber 32 vs. 32 ist es clusterfuck extrem. Teilweise auch kaum durchkommen.
Okay, die hat aber gut weggespammt.
Du, du, du, du, du.
Ich glaube, ich habe nie Granatenwerfer gespielt in dem Game.
Oh, die Gegner, da werden sie weggespray. Aber Leute, gestern, wir haben ja gestern eineinhalb Stunden Battlefield 3 bisschen gestreamt, bis zum Mittagessen.
Gestern haben wir auch ein paar richtig geile Gegner wegspray Momente gehabt.
Gerade auf Firestorm an der letzten Base, da haben wir keine Ahnung, 20 Gegner weggespray.
Vielleicht sollte ich das auch mal einreichen für Top Plays.
Aber das war nicht schnell genug hintereinander.
Ja, der checkt nichts. Und da stehen sie drin und machen nichts. Und was? Was? Okay, Leute, was ist mit dem Dude hier los? Das kann doch nicht dem sein Ernst sein. Ist der AFK?
Oder absolut Hardcore im Scope, ja.
Stimmt, man konnte unter die Bahn. Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt, wo ich sehe, stimmt, man konnte sich da drunter legen.
Du, du, du, du, du.
Was machen die Gegner? Warum stehen die da alle auf dem Zug drauf?
Okay, die checken wieder nichts.
Haha, wie sie rein rennen. Das kann mir jetzt keiner erzählen, das ist nur weil dein Schalldämpfer hat, keiner mitkriegt. Da musst du schon echt hardcore blind sein für.
Das wars.
Oh, da werden sie weggesprayt.
Sowas hatte ich gestern auf Grand Bazaar auch. Äh, nicht Grand Bazaar, auf Sand Crossing auch.
Da habe ich irgendwie acht Magazine in einen Gang reingeschossen und jedes Mal fünf Leute gekillt. Am Ende hatte ich 70 Kills.
Nee, mehr. Glaub sogar fast 90 Kills.
Aber das war auch 64 oder 68, 48 Mann.
Ja, Instant Revive.
Objektiv gesehen finde ich die Revive Geschichte aus Battlefield 4 am besten.
Du hast die Chance Leute schnell wiederzubeleben und du hast die Chance Leute ausführlich wiederzubeleben.
Ich mochte das in Battlefield 3, dass es halt so richtig, dass das Game so richtig intensiv und schnell gemacht hat mit dem, mit dem 100% Instant Revive.
Aber objektiv gesehen denke ich kann man sagen, dass Battlefield 4 das beste Revive System hat.
Battlefield 4 konntest du aber über drei Kilometer wiederbeleben.
Hallo.
Lookin' knifed. Wieder keiner was am checken.
Mit Webcam. Der wills aber wissen.
Professional Streaming Battlefield 3 by the way 2020.
Ich bin immer noch dafür, dass die einfach Battlefield 3 und 4 nehmen sollten und daraus ein neues Free to Play oder Service Game machen, was sie weiter versorgen mit Updates.
Und sie müssen ja nicht Battlefield 3 und 4 in der Form nehmen, sie können den Kram importieren in die aktuelle Frostbite Variante und ein bisschen dran rumschrauben noch.
Oh die werden weggesprayt.
Ja mit dem Unterschied der Rapidler, dass Battlefield 5 gesackt hat.
Battlefield 3 hätte ich mir gewünscht, dass es länger als die kurze Lebenszeit, die das Game hatte. Battlefield 3 ging ja nur eineinhalb Jahre oder so, bevor Battlefield 4 kam.
Hätten sie Battlefield 3 mal ordentlich versorgt anstatt ein neues zu machen. Oder hätten sie Battlefield 4 länger versorgt und hätten sie einen besseren Zustand rausgebracht.
Die sollten das Free to Play machen. Ich glaube das ist die Zukunft für hohe Spielerzahlen.
Wer spielt denn sowas? 1.94 mit den Standard Iron Sides.
Hat aber Glück gehabt, dass der letzte eben noch in die Kugel gerannt ist.
Ja lohnt nichts aber auf allen Plattformen.
Black Ops 1 hatte nur auf der Xbox schon eine Million Multiplayer gehabt damals.
Das war halt die Hochzeit von Call of Duty.
Battlefield Free to Play wäre für die Marke echt nicht verkehrt.
Es gibt auch so viele Varianten wie du Multiplayer-Spiele monetarisieren kannst mittlerweile.
Ich rede nicht davon, dass Firestorm Free to Play machen soll. Gerade weil es nicht Free to Play war. Die sollen ein richtig ordentliches Battlefield Free to Play machen.
Nicht unbedingt darauf aufspringen, was 3 Milliarden andere auch schon machen.
Ich finde, dass Modern Warfare mit Battlefield überhaupt nichts zu tun hat.
Ich habe jetzt ja beides viel gespielt.
Der Unterschied zwischen dem großen Maps im Modern Warfare Multiplayer und dem großen Maps im Modern Warfare Multiplayer
und dem großen Maps im Modern Warfare Multiplayer im Battlefield sind, dass Battlefield eine Frontline hat.
Und Modern Warfare absolut nichts dergleichen und einfach random ist im Multiplayer.
Battlefield weißt du immer halbwegs wo Gegner sein können.
Das ganze gibt es im Modern Warfare Multiplayer nicht. Erst mal schön geteabacked.
Gibt es die Waffe nicht auch im Modern Warfare?
Oh, den hat er aber schön geaimt. Vor allem in der Bewegung komplett drauf geblieben. Das war gut.
Ja, die Steam Releases sind ziemlich dämlich. Du brauchst immer noch Origin. Das ist zu tief in dem Game integriert. Das ist Fail.
Exzellent. Da hast du fast zwei habe ich nicht gekauft. Aber ich habe mich spoilern lassen und fand das was gespoilt wurde echt doof.
Oh, Claymore Camper gibt es die jetzt auch schon in Battlefield 4. Titanfall 2 wird wieder gezockt. Warum das denn? Ist gerade free to play oder was?
Das sehe ich auch sehr selten. Achso, weil sie auf Steam sind. Stimmt, das war ja auch Origin Exklusiv. Ganz vergessen.
Der Sound klingt komisch bei dem Clip.
Er schießt geradeaus und man hört es nur rechts. Metacritic. Ja, die Metacritic Leute regen sich über die Story auf.
Aber wie gesagt kann ich verstehen. Das was ich mir habe spoilern lassen für Last of Us 2 hat mir auch überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Ich spoilere euch jetzt aber nicht.
Schön weggesprayt. Guck mal, Putin 69 spielt. Da kann ja nichts schief gehen.
Die sind ja komplett dämlich die Gegner.
Low brain. Low IQ Gegner.
Jetzt stirbt er. Der stirbt nicht? Doch. Da waren so viele Gegner um ihn. Er hatte noch 3% Leben.
Mein Take on why Battlefield 5 failed. Komm, das gucken wir uns auch noch an.
Wobei der ist immer so resident sleeper. Ich kann mir das 16 Minuten von ihm nicht geben.
Wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen?
1,25 hört es doch richtig gut an, oder?
Das stimmt. Das Game macht kein Geld.
Das hat kein Geld gemacht.
Leute, wisst ihr worauf ich hoffe bei Battlefield 6 vom Namen her? Das ist, dass die die Benamung weglassen.
Die sollen die Benamung wegschmeißen. Scheiß drauf. Die Benamung ist eh schon kaputt seit Battlefield 1.
Die sollen es weglassen. Die sollen es einfach Battlefield und Untertitel nennen und gut ist.
Und dass Battlefield 5 so abgekackt ist, wenn man den Leuten sagt sie sollen es nicht kaufen, dann kaufen sie es halt nicht.
Selbst schuld.
Das Video ist mir zu langweilig. Das passiert zu wenig.
Das ist ultra big brain dieses Video Leute. Das Video ist extrem big brain.
Das ist richtig big brain.
Jetzt, wie ist das möglich? Wie funktioniert das? Und wichtig ist, warum ist das wichtig zu beginnen?
Ich werde das alles in diesem Video unterbreiten. Aber bevor wir in die Details der RNG in diesem Video gehen...
Apex Legends kommt auf Switch. Ja, habe ich gehört.
Das Video ist so extrem big brain, das ist richtig clever was die da gebaut haben für Squids.
In Wind Waker gibt es das Schiffe versenken Minigame. Das Problem ist, dass das Schiffe versenken komplett random ist.
Das ist relativ spät in dem Run. Selbst wenn du bis dahin ziemlich gut warst und schlechte random Sachen erwischt, dann kannst du halt neu starten.
Das ist extrem big brain, wie die das gelöst haben. Die haben nämlich was programmiert, um das Minigame weniger random zu machen.
Und ohne irgendwie die Konsole RAM auszulesen, das wäre ja cheapen.
Tatsche für versenken.
Selbst wenn du die besten Schüsse schießt, hast du eine sehr geringe Wahrheit, dass du diese Schüsse schießt.
Das sagt, stellt euch mal vor, man hat einen richtig guten Run abgeliefert, 30 Minuten, und danach hat man einfach schlechtes RNG in so einem Minigame neu anfangen.
Und ein Viertel der Runs geht da nur durch. Das ist schon ziemlich frustrierend für Speedrunner.
Jetzt kommt big brain.
Das ist ja noch leiser. Ich sage jetzt nicht, was ich gerade aus Versehen gelesen habe hier oben.
Das ist nicht so wichtig, aber die erklären halt, was sie machen danach.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Wind Waker in Python programmiert ist.
Der war schlecht, ich gebe es zu.
Und jetzt waren wir wieder sauer.
Sobald ein Rund in 30 Minuten einen Sploosh-Kaboom bekommt,
gibt es keinen richtigen Weg zu wissen, wo wir in der RNG-Zeit sind.
An diesem Punkt haben wir endlich genau herausgefunden, wie die RNG funktioniert,
wie die RNG generiert wird, und wir haben sehr viel progress gemacht.
Jedoch gibt es ein Problem.
Wie man am Ende des Videos mit Sunday sehen kann, gibt es ein großes Problem,
und das sind die wenigen Calls pro Fram, die RNG macht.
Z.B. 20x, 100x pro Fram.
Also, um das zusammenzufassen, was das Problem ist, die wissen, wie das Spiel sein Random-Zeug generiert.
Das Problem ist nur, sie wissen nicht, welche Random-Nummer als nächstes dran kommt.
Also, wenn du so ein normaler RNG-Generator, wenn du den mit der gleichen Zahl startest,
kommt immer die gleiche Zeichenfolge raus.
Das muss man wissen.
Also, sprich, egal welchen RNG-Generator man verwendet,
RNG-Generator man verwendet, wenn man an dem gleichen Punkt startet,
ist die Zahlenfolge immer dieselbe.
So, das heißt, selbst wenn sie wissen, mit was das startet,
und sie wissen, welche Random-Nummer-Folge kommt,
sie wissen nicht, wo sie quasi in der milliardenlangen Liste der möglichen Zufallsteilen gerade sind.
Wenn sie das wüssten, könnten sie auch sagen, welche Zahl als nächstes kommt.
Und nachdem das ganze 30 Minuten quasi in dem Run erst vorkommt,
wurde der Random-Number-Generator so oft aufgerufen,
dass die keine Ahnung haben, wo sie gerade sind und welche Random-Number als nächstes dran kommt.
Jetzt kommt Big Brain, was die machen, das ist richtig geil.
Die erklärt es vorher noch, dass man es am Ende versteht, aber das ist Massive Big Brain.
Okay, wir sehen das Tool in Aktion, jetzt erzählen wir euch, wie es funktioniert.
Es gibt ca. 604.000 möglichen Squid-Layouts, und es scheint, dass das Spiel sie alle mit ungefähr gleicher Probabilität generiert hat.
Aber sagen wir mal, wir wussten magisch, dass nur einige Squid-Layouts möglich waren,
sagen wir mal, diese zwölf Boarden, wir nennen sie unsere Kandidaten-Boards.
Was wir tun können, ist, ein Heatmap zu generieren, wo Squid-Layouts von unseren Kandidaten-Boards möglich sind.
Starten wir mit dem Ignoren, welche Squid-Layouts welche sind, und nur darauf achten, welche Zellen eigentlich Squid-Layouts enthalten.
Hier habe ich eine Heatmap für jede Board individuell produziert.
Dann können wir diese Heatmaps zusammen averageieren, um eine gesamte Heatmap zu generieren.
Dieser Verteil in jeder Zelle sagt, dass der Verteil von Boarden eine Squid-Layout in dieser Stelle enthält.
Und weil wir erlauben, dass all diese Boarden gleichwertig sind, ist das auch die Probabilität, eine Squid-Layout zu finden in dieser Zelle.
Hier werden alle Boarden zusammen averageiert.
Und wenn wir fertig sind...
Eine bestimmte Zelle hier hat eine 58% Chance, eine Squid-Layout zu enthalten.
Also sagen wir mal, dass der User in dieser Zelle ein Verlust hat.
Dann können wir alle Boarden, die eine Squid-Layout enthält, in dieser Stelle regeln.
Das sind diese Boarden.
Jetzt, dass wir diese Boarden regeln, ist es unmöglich, eine neue Heatmap zu generieren, um die restlichen Boarden zu averageieren.
Hier sehen wir das passiert.
Und jetzt wissen wir, dass diese Zelle hier eine 60% Chance, eine Squid-Layout zu enthalten hat.
Sagen wir mal, dass der User in dieser Zelle ein Verlust hat, und jetzt können wir alle Boarden, die eine Squid-Layout enthält, regeln.
Das sind diese beiden.
Und wiederum können wir eine neue Heatmap generieren, die mit der Information, die wir jetzt haben, kompatibel ist.
Dann können wir in dieser Zelle ein Verlust haben. Sagen wir mal, dass wir einen Verlust haben.
Dann können wir diese Boarden regeln.
Ich glaube jetzt hat jeder verstanden, was sie prinzipiell machen.
Wir haben jetzt zwei Boarden übrig.
Und an diesem Punkt können wir in jeder dieser 50-50 Zellen ein Verlust haben.
Sagen wir mal, dass wir hier ein Verlust haben.
Dann können wir diese Boarden regeln.
Und jetzt wissen wir genau, was die Squid-Layout ist.
Und nun ist der User frei, die restlichen Squids zu schießen, so schnell wie möglich.
Es ist also klar, dass die Name des Spiels die möglichen Boarden enthalten.
Aber wie können wir das tun?
Um das zu tun, müssen wir die RNG verstehen.
Wie vorhin erwähnt, nutzt die Wind Waker einen festen Seed für die RNG.
Das ist das Big Brain, Leute.
Das muss man sagen.
Jedes Game von Wind Waker, was ich starte, jedes.
Ob das jetzt bei euch ist oder bei mir.
Die Reihenfolge von Zufallsteilen ist immer die gleiche.
Das muss man generell bei Zufallsteilen-Generator sagen.
Die Reihenfolge ist immer die gleiche.
Egal ob euer Gamecube oder mein Gamecube oder meine Wii oder sonst was.
Die Reihenfolge, wie das Game Zufallsteilen generiert,
und die Zufallsteilen sind nicht zufällig in der Reihenfolge,
sondern die Reihenfolge ist immer gleich.
Die Reihenfolge, wie das Game Zufallsteilen generiert,
ist immer gleich.
um zu zeigen, welches RNG-Value von welchen Frames verwendet wird.
Also sagen wir, das erste Frame des Spiels verwendet diese ersten 13 RNG-Valuen.
Wenn wir magisch auf den zweiten Frame des Spiels auf Splishkaboom teleportieren würden,
dann würden wir dieses Board hier zeigen.
Und in der Wahrheit würde das Board selbst einige randome Nummern verwendet werden.
Wenn wir auf Splishkaboom einen einzigen Frame später zeigen würden,
würden wir ein völlig anderes Board haben.
Ein Frame später, ein anderes Board.
Also man sieht, man kann nach 30 Minuten Run nicht predikten,
so ohne weiteres, was für ein Board kommt.
Das klingt einfach perfekt, aber wie ich schon gesagt habe, ist es schlimmer als das.
Wenn es ein bisschen mehr in Frame 4 gewesen wäre,
dann hätten wir vielleicht ein paar mehr randome Nummern verwendet.
Und wir hätten sogar ein anderes Board verwendet.
Also man kann nicht einfach nur so ein Frame-perfektes Setup machen,
das Spiel zu wiederholen, um das 100, 100, 100-RNG-Stat zu bekommen,
und dann auf Splishkaboom in ein bestimmtes Niveau von Frames zu kommen.
Nein, es ist viel mehr präziser als das.
Aber man könnte denken, okay, wir müssen nicht genau wissen,
wann wir auf Splishkaboom zeigen.
Wie wir vorhin gesagt haben, müssen wir nur ein limited Set von Möglichkeiten für das Board haben.
Also schauen wir uns an, wie wir das machen.
Let's say, we instead of just having a specific RNG value,
that we want to show up to Splishkaboom at,
we're going to have a range of possible RNG values
and a probability distribution over them.
We're going to show that on the y-axis here with a probability distribution.
Ich finde es halt geil, es ist ein bisschen viel Setup
für das, was im Endeffekt jetzt gleich noch gezeigt wird.
Aber ich finde es halt geil, wie du quasi aus nichts im Endeffekt was machen kannst.
Also wo jeder erstmal denken würde, okay, es ist halt einfach Zufall.
Und wenn man sich dann genauer anguckt, kann man Zufall, so zufällig ist der Zufall gar nicht.
So let's look at what Board we would get if we showed up to Splishkaboom in each of these RNG Step Counts.
Here we can see that for every RNG Step Count, you just get a completely different Board.
It's not like if you show up at RNG Step Count 15, you get a Board that's similar to this Board you would get if you showed up at 14 Steps.
So given all these Boards, maybe we think that we're going to show up to Splishkaboom around RNG Step 15.
Could be less, could be more, could be as little as 10, as much as 20.
Probably not anything outside of that region.
Then we can do exactly what we showed before, making a heat map.
And this time we're going to take a weighted average of all of the Boards under this belt curve.
Es wird aber gleich noch ein bisschen schwieriger für den Programmierer dieser App.
Weil erstens muss man natürlich sagen, Memory-Auslesen vom Gamecube ist verboten.
Und irgendwelche Sachen automatisiert im Speedrun-Auslesen ist auch verboten.
Das kommt ja noch dabei, also das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Das heißt, die müssen sich komplett auf Timing verlassen. Er erklärt's.
Nee, sind wir nicht.
Das Problem ist, dass man nicht 30 Sachen zur Auswahl hat, sondern Millionen Sachen zur Auswahl hat.
Und für so einen Zeitraum, beziehungsweise für so eine riesen Menge an möglichen Random-Zahlen, kannst du sowas hier nicht machen.
Weil dann hätte jedes Feld keine Ahnung, wie man das machen kann.
Und das ist auch ein Problem.
Und für so eine riesen Menge an möglichen Random-Zahlen, kannst du sowas hier nicht machen, weil dann hätte jedes Feld, keine Ahnung, ungefähr die gleiche Chance.
Und wenn wir das gleiche Abwärtsprozess machen würden, wie ich es vorhin gezeigt habe,
würden wir eine Heizung bekommen, die so ähnlich aussieht.
Es wäre eigentlich flach.
Sicher ist es etwas weniger möglich, weil es schwerer ist, ein Squid zu befinden.
Aber das ist eigentlich nur die Information, die du bekommen würdest, ohne any Wissen.
Also, das wird also nicht funktionieren.
Wir müssen etwas etwas mehr fiskantieren.
Also, wir gucken mal, was das mehr fiskantierte ist.
Um das zu erklären, gehe ich durch ein Video von Blinkis, das das Tool eigentlich nutzt.
Ich werde vorwärts verabschieden.
Das wird das komplizierte Teil des Videos sein.
Um es ein bisschen einfacher zu verstehen, werde ich eine Zeitlinie an den Boden des Bildes legen.
Auf der linken Seite dieser Zeitlinie wird der kritische Moment sein, als das Spiel beginnt.
Und wir initialisieren den RNG zu 100, 100, 100.
Sie haben übrigens richtig Glück, dass die Zelda-Programmierer faul gewesen sind und immer den gleichen Seat genommen haben.
Das Bild wird in die schwarze Linie gefadet und ich werde das Video pausieren.
Also, sobald das Bild in die schwarze Linie gefadet wird, wird das Spiel mit dem RNG das erste Board generiert.
Das ist ein extrem wichtiges Moment, also lasst uns das auf unsere Zeitlinie markieren.
Ich werde jetzt wieder das Video spielen und wir werden Blinkis das erste Board spielen sehen.
Jetzt kommt der eigentliche Knackpunkt, wie sie rausbekommen können, welche Boards infrage kommen.
Jetzt kommt der eigentliche Knackpunkt.
Genau.
Der weiß, dass das erste Board eh nicht hinhaut.
Und die Chance ist zu groß, dass das Ding das Ding kann das noch nicht richtig predicten.
Aber anhand der Ecke, ich muss ja nicht erklären, er erklärt es ja.
Okay, ich habe das Video wieder pausiert.
Das ist ein wichtiges Moment.
Blinkis wird gleich A drücken, um das Board rauszunehmen.
Und das ist der exakte Moment, dass es das nächste Board generiert.
Ich weiß, dass das ein bisschen seltsam klingt.
Man könnte erwarten, dass es das nächste Board in der Dialoge generiert.
Aber nein, es generiert es tatsächlich in diesem Moment.
Das ist auch sehr wichtig, also lasst uns das auf unsere Zeitlinie markieren.
Okay, ich beginne das Video wieder zu spielen.
Mal sehen, was passiert.
Blinkis spricht, um ein anderes Spiel zu beginnen.
Und dann kommt er auf das Board.
Okay, also das ist das erste Spiel, in dem wir Blinkis gewinnen möchten.
Haben wir genug Informationen?
Lass uns über die Informationen denken.
Ich werde Blinkis in die rechten Körner legen.
Und wir werden die Anzeige, die wir vorher hatten, für RNG-Staffs gegen Probabilität drehen.
Blinkis hat das am Anfang erklärt.
Das wird von dieser Bell-Kurve von unserer Meinung indikiert.
Blinkis könnte an mehr oder weniger, sagen wir, ein paar Hunderttausend Staffs zeigen.
Außerdem kennen wir auch das erste Board, das generiert wurde.
Und das ist dieses Board hier.
Und auch wissen wir, dass bestimmte RNG-Staffkonten bestimmte Boards generieren.
Also das erste Board war nur möglich,
bei einigen Subseten der möglichen RNG-Staffkonten.
Lassen wir sagen, dass es nur bei diesen vier Staffkonten möglich war.
Also die linken und rechten Staffkonten
sehen sehr unwahrscheinlich aus,
wenn wir denken, dass Blinkis zu Sploosh-Kaboom gekommen ist.
Also lassen wir diese komplett vergleichen.
Wir sind left mit diesen zwei Staffkonten.
Und wir können eigentlich die entsprechende Probabilität von dieser Bell-Kurve estimieren.
Also, wir denken, dass diese linken Staffkonten,
die etwa 5.389.276 Staffkonten sind,
etwa 30% möglich sind, und die andere RNG-Staffkonten etwa 70% möglich sind.
Also, um zu erheben,
sind diese zwei RNG-Staffkonten die einzige Möglichkeit,
als das erste Board generiert wurde.
Und diese sind ihre entsprechenden Probabilitäten.
Außerdem wissen wir, wie viel Zeit zwischen dem ersten Board und dem zweiten,
hier auf der Zeitlinie, generiert wurde.
Wie bereits erwähnt,
in Sploosh-Kaboom-Ruim
gibt es ca. 8 RNG-Kollegen pro Fram.
Von diesem Zeitpunkt können wir eine ziemlich gute Estimation
von wie viele RNG-Staffkonten
zwischen dem ersten und dem zweiten Board generiert wurden.
Mit all dieser Informationen
können wir eine erhebliche Probabilität für den RNG-Staffkonten produzieren,
bei dem der zweite Board generiert wurde.
Diese Erhebungen sind eine große Bell-Kurve und zwei kleine Bell-Kurve.
Jedes dieser Erhebungen ist eigentlich eine kleine Bell-Kurve mit einer sehr langen Variante.
Zwei Erhebungen, weil wir noch nicht sicher sind,
ob die erste Board generiert wurde.
Wenn nicht, ist es auch egal.
Er zeigt gleich die App und dann wird klar, was sie eigentlich machen.
... die ersten Board generiert wurden.
Um den Punkt zu erheben,
wenn die Zeit zwischen dem zweiten Board und dem ersten Board
ein bisschen höher gewesen wäre,
würden wir die Erhebungen anstattdessen ein bisschen weiter zu der rechten.
Aber das ist das, was wir eigentlich haben.
Wegen dieser Probabilität
können wir die ganze Erhebungsprozesse von vorher
um das Board zu erheben.
Schauen wir uns das Video an.
Ich spiele es jetzt.
Es geht schnell vorbei,
aber schaut mal, wie schnell die Erhebungsprozesse,
die in der linken Seite gezeigt wird,
auf dem Board schäumt, als Linkes Schotzen nimmt.
Nach nur ein paar Schotzen,
die er vorbeigeschossen hat,
konnte er ziemlich genau einschätzen.
Das kann es nicht sein. Update das und jetzt weiß er genau, wo er hinschießen muss.
Das ist richtig big brain.
Alles schon geil, oder?
Und wohlgemerkt,
ohne irgendwie in das Game einzugreifen,
das ist ja gerade der Witz daran,
da wird nichts ausgelesen,
nichts screen captured oder sonst was.
Das läuft rein nebenbei
und das Einzige, was er macht, ist, er tippt auf dem Tablet.
Der hat auf dem Tablet oder auf dem Desktop, wo auch immer,
hat er die App
und er macht den Input mit dem Controller
und mit der anderen Hand macht er den Input in der App.
Also ist alles manuell.
Ja, jetzt ist es easy, das rauszubekommen.
Und jetzt ist es eigentlich total simpel, das rauszukriegen an der Stelle,
weil es haben es auch nicht mehr zwei Varianten,
sondern sie wissen genau, auf welchem Stand sie waren
und können es fürs dritte einfach berechnen.
Easy.
Guckt mal, guckt euch die App unten links an hier.
Zack, miss.
Guckt, er kennt sofort,
wo er hinschießen muss.
Das ist richtig big brain.
Easy light sagt, ich habe verpasst,
ich habe verpasst, ich habe verpasst, ich habe verpasst.
Das wurde im Endprojekt.
Sie wissen die Zeit ungefähr und so ungefähr wie viele Random Steps gelaufen sind.
Und danach gucken sie einfach, danach schießt der Random, danach schießt der Random einfach
mal ein Einmal Minigame rum und anhand dieser Informationen, was da rauskommt an Hit und
Miss, können sie das ganz gut eingrenzen, was in diesem Zeitraum möglich ist.
Wurde gesagt, woher sie wissen, wie mit den Zahlen das Board generiert wird, das haben
sie nicht erklärt, quasi wie sie von Boards auf Zufallszahlen kommen und von Zufallszahlen
auf Boards.
Da vermute ich mal, dass sie einfach sich den ROM, dass irgendjemand sich die ROM genommen
hat und dort Reverse-engineert hat.
Gehe ich mal von aus.
Achso, ja, da gehe ich mal von aus, das hat irgendwie einer aus dem ROM-Reverse-engineert,
wie das funktioniert.
X-Faith für 12 Monate, Dankeschön.
Oder ich weiß nicht, ob es auf Github ist, ist das auf Github?
Ja, hier, Github, da ist es doch, ja, das ist die App, also Github.
Zweitens, wie ist das Programm, wenn man weiß, wo man geschossen hat, ob es ein Hit und
ein Miss war oder ob ein Squid getötet wurde?
Also, viele Leute denken, dass es die Erinnerungen von der Spielkonsole, von Homebrew oder von
einem Screen Capturing-Tool nimmt, aber es benutzt nichts davon.
Es ist eigentlich alles komplett manuell gemacht und das ist der einzige Grund, warum es
zu Beginn geht, denn alles ist manuell gemacht.
Du wirst dich vielleicht fragen, warte, aber wie hat das Programm so schnell verabschiedet?
Es ist einfach viel Praxis.
Ich halte meinen Controller mit einer Hand und dann stelle ich meine andere Hand auf
den Keyboard, damit ich ihn mit einer Hand schiebe und dann benutze ich meine Fingern in
meinem Keyboard, um den Hit, Miss oder getötetem Squid mit einer Hotkey zu machen, damit ich
viel schneller Input haben kann, wenn es Hits oder Misses gibt.
Das ist also, wie man die Geschwindigkeit aufbaut, um es noch schneller zu machen.
Du hast die Praxis, mit einer Hand den Controller zu machen, aber du kannst es mit zwei Händen
machen, es ist nur etwas schneller.
Du wirst dich vielleicht auch fragen, welche Versionen das funktioniert, und ich bin froh,
dass ich dir sage, dass das jetzt auf jede Version des Spiels funktioniert.
Das funktioniert auf jede Gamecube-Release des Spiels und jede einzelne Wii-Release des
Spiels.
HD und Gamecube.
Also, jede Version kann das benutzen, jeder kann dieses Programm benutzen, es ist absolut
wunderschön.
Ich möchte auch schnell sagen, dass ich denke, dass alle, die hier zusammengekommen sind,
um dieses Programm tatsächlich zu machen...
Was macht da eigentlich das Tentakel im Hintergrund?
Ich werde jetzt eine Liste auf dem Schrank von jeder Person, die mit diesem Programm
geholfen hat.
Und das betrifft alle, wie Peter, Kreis, Genko, Trog, Lang, C-Sundae, Shao, Schnapps, die
Leute aus der NSA, die ein Werkzeug entwickelt haben, welches wir tatsächlich nutzen konnten,
um den Kode des Spiels zu kompilieren.
Die schönen Entwickler aus Dolphin, die das möglich gemacht haben, und die Leute, die
den Erinnerungsmotor entwickelt haben, um die Erinnerungswerte zu lesen, während das Spiel
los war.
Alle, die zusammengekommen sind, um dieses Ding möglich zu machen, danke euch so sehr.
Das wäre nicht möglich gewesen, ohne alle anderen, und ich möchte es sehr klar machen,
dass das ein riesiges Gemeinschaftsverfahren war, und das nicht von einer einzelnen Person gemacht
werden konnte.
Schönen Schock an alle, die zusammengekommen sind, für das.
Jetzt möchte ich euch schnell einen Clip von dem Resultat aller so schweren Arbeit zeigen.
Also genießt diesen Clip schnell.
Okay, ich glaube, ich werde dieses Spiel verlieren.
Nun mit all dem gesagt, ist das hier, wo ich dieses Video enden werde.
Ich fand das richtig, huge big brain, Alter, richtig, richtig geil.
Am Anfang denkt man nämlich, und es gibt viele Probleme, gerade, wenn man Sachen programmiert,
viele Sachen, wo man anfangen denkt, so irgendwie, boah, das kann ja nicht funktionieren, und
wenn man sich das immer in kleinere Teile anguckt, irgendwann kommt man dann manchmal
drauf, so, ja, das könnte doch funktionieren, und wie er ja auch gesagt hat, das ist nicht
jetzt mal so, eben bei am Wochenende von einer Person entstanden, da hat, da hat ziemlich
viel dazugehört.
Richtig big brain Programm hier, huge, um nichts, um nichts zu sagen, äh.
Okay, ich glaube, das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Oh, Grip, äh, ich muss mal kurz die Klimaanlage anmachen, so, also, ich habe übrigens jetzt
Essen am Start, d.h. eigentlich müsste ich jetzt Schluss machen, weil ich will euch nichts
vorschmatzen und ich kann auch nicht in Ruhe essen im Stream, wir machen das mal so, wir
speichern uns die offenen Videos, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch, Hexomythen, sonst
was, jetzt kann ich euch auch mal hier Trick 17 zeigen, kennt, kennt ihr das schon?
Das hier, man kann das oben markieren, und dann geht man auf Bookmark All Tabs, dann
speichert man sich das neue Folder, äh, keine Ahnung, merken da rein, und dann guckt man
hier, merken, zack, äh, ups, ah, ah, passt schon, da ist alles, machen wir noch das Datum
dran, rename, ein zwanzigste, sechste, das ist ein richtig big brain Feature, und dann
schaut man nie wieder rein, ja, das stimmt, aber in dem Fall will ich die Sachen ja bis
nächstes Mal angucken.
Session Manager geht genauso, ne Leute, ich geh jetzt off, ich geh jetzt off und ess was,
ich hab Hunger, äh, außerdem muss ich mal aufs Klo, reicht, vielleicht spielen wir nachher
noch ne Runde Battlefield, mal gucken, bis später, macht's gut, oder bis morgen, oder
so, mal schauen, bis denn, see you.